this is jocko podcast number 316 with
echo charles and me jocko willink good
evening econ good evening
december 18th uh 2018
general jim mattis
resigned as a secretary of defense for
donald trump and he did that he wrote a
letter and in that letter he said quote
because you have the right to a
secretary of defense whose views are
better aligned with yours
i believe it is right for me to step
down from my position
then
clearly general mattis did not agree
with
what donald trump was doing or how
donald trump was doing what he was doing
and so
he stepped down and you can read that
letter online the letter of resignation
and it's
he did it in
as respectfully as he could i think
after he did that things went got a
little bit worse
between the two of them but the initial
statement was certainly meant to be done
in a
respectful way to
from the from the secretary of defense
to the commander-in-chief but it was
certainly a statement
by him stepping down
when that happened i was definitely
disappointed to see
general mattis
leaving that position
and because then it then it's a
situation where he no longer has any
influence over what's happening
and general mattis highly respected
marine and leader in the military
but this kind of thing has happened
before
a harder line was taken by colonel david
hackworth when he spoke out against
both military and civilian leadership
in his interview toward the end of the
vietnam war
interview with a news program called
issues and answers sunday june 7 1971.
here's some things here's some excerpts
from that interview and the whole
interviews in the book about face
but some of the excerpts from that
he was being interviewed by a guy named
mr tuchner mr tuchner said in your view
did poor training lead to higher
casualties in vietnam
colonel hackworth replied i am convinced
of it
i think that our casualties were at
least 30 percent higher because of or
even higher than that but i'd say just
safely 30 percent because of troops that
were not properly trained i participated
in a study group in the pentagon in 67
and 68
which considered u.s casualties caused
by friendly fires and the group was
composed of highly experienced personnel
that had served in vietnam and it was
our conclusion that 15 to 20 percent of
the casualties caused in vietnam were
the result of friendly fire one man
shooting another man artillery friendly
fire
friendly artillery fire firing on a
friendly element friendly helicopters
firing on a friendly unit attack
airstrike on a friendly unit
and i could count you in my own case
countless personal examples
for example during the battle of dak ii
june the 17th a rocket ship came into my
a company's position by mistake and
released its rockets right on top of the
company killing the executive officer
and wounding 29 other troopers
i can recall in september of 1965 as my
battalion was deployed artillery was
fired in the wrong place killing seven
men in one of my platoons
the interview goes on mr tuchner says
did the upper echelon of the army really
ever become changed on this war
did they learn from their mistakes
colonel hackworth i don't think so
i don't think that the top level ever
developed a realistic strategic plan nor
did they ever have tactics to support
that strategic plan
and that is why perhaps we who have not
been vocal should be charged for
criminal neglect because it is our
obligation it is our responsibility not
only to train our soldiers well to lead
our soldiers well but to make sure that
there are no mistakes made that they are
protected as well as possible from
mistakes and error and once you make
mistakes they must be surfaced critiqued
identified and remedial action taken
the interview goes on
and it closes out with this mr tuchner
asks colonel
do you feel it is possible you have
become too emotionally involved in
vietnam
colonel hackworth replies
i have become emotionally involved in
vietnam
one couldn't have spent the number of
years i've spent in vietnam without
becoming emotionally involved one
couldn't see the number of young studs
die or be terribly wounded without
becoming emotionally involved
i just have seen the american nation
spend so much of its wonderful great
young men in this country i've seen our
national wealth being drained away i see
the nation being split apart and almost
being split asunder because of this war
and i am wondering to what end
it is all going to lead to
obviously hackworth was drummed out of
the army shortly after that interview
hackworth and mattis are not the first
people to resign in protest or because
they didn't agree with what was
happening
in fact another guy that hackworth
refers to
is general
william billy mitchell father of the air
force world war one commanded the first
aircraft our first american aircraft
world war one and after the war he
started to build
the air force
and guess what the army and the navy
kind of objected to it because they they
thought that their ways were better
and they he conducted field tests
against navy ships used an aircraft and
proved that
we needed air power
and there was a navy airship like a
blimp
called the shenandoah crashed in 1925 14
crew were killed
and mitchell
general mitchell protested to the press
openly accusing the war department of
quote incompetence and criminal
negligence
saying quote brave airmen are being sent
to their deaths by armchair admirals who
don't care about their safety
mitchell was court-martialed
convicted of insubordination and facing
a five-year suspension he resigned his
commission 1949
the sec nav the secretary of the navy
resigned
as the construction of the super carrier
the uss united states was cut to pay for
the air force b-36 long-range bomber
program
if you ever read the book
dereliction of duty
by h.r mcmaster
another highly respected
general
and one of the things he refers to
during the vietnam war that the joint
chiefs of staff
for lyndon b johnson
he calls them five silent men
because they didn't push back
on some of the things
or a lot of the things
or all of the things that lbj and
mcnamara were doing
the army chief harold johnson general
harold johnson said after his retirement
after he retired
he said quote i remember the day i was
ready to go over to the oval office and
give my four stars to the president and
tell him
quote you have refused to tell the
country they cannot fight a war without
mobilization you have required me to
send men into battle with little hope of
their ultimate victory and you have
forced us into the military and forced
the military to violate almost every one
of the principles of war in vietnam
therefore i resign and i will hold a
press conference after i walk out your
door
but of course he didn't do that
that's something he said later
general wallace green marine corps
marine corps chief
and this is a guy that in world war ii
fought the japanese
with a 45 caliber pistol and a bayonet
and he says in that same book in that
book by mcmaster
he says something along the lines of
well if i resign in protest okay i'm in
the headlines for 48 hours then what
then i'm gone and someone else carries
on i don't have an impact and that's a
decent point
it's a legitimate point made by green
same thing i said about matters when you
leave again it's a decision but when you
leave you've got to realize that your
influence is gone
1968
cyrus vance
who was a world war ii navy gunnery
officer
he was he did resign
as lbj's deputy secretary of defense
in protest to what was going on in
vietnam which he initially believed in
vietnam war but as he saw it unfold he
said this is not a good idea and he
eventually resigned
he also later resigned as a secretary of
state for carter for jimmy carter in
protest of desert one
because he thought that we should
negotiate more
he did that two times
i don't think either one of them had a
huge impact 1997 air force chief of
staff decorated vietnam war pilot
resigned at the perceived punishment
that was to be imposed on the commanders
on the ground when the khobar towers
were attacked in saudi arabia
2006
a guy named aaron watada
army
refused to go to iraq didn't believe in
the war resigned
matthew ho a former marine infantry
officer
in 2009 resigned in protest as a senior
political civilian representative in
zabul province in afghanistan wrote a
scathing letter
you can read that online
2021 lieutenant colonel paul douglas
hague
resigned in objection to quote
traitorous withdrawal from afghanistan
and also talked about an ideological
marxist takeover of the military and the
united states government at their upper
echelons
resigned
so
these things happen
and i talked about this in the book
leadership strategy and tactics i talked
about
when you should do this how you make
that decision because when you resign
or even when you speak out aggressively
and ostracize yourself as a leader you
no longer have influence over the
situation
you're gone
maybe your statement
will will bring about enough
highlight
will bring enough light on the subject
that you can help that that your
resignation can help that's what you
hope for
but
it's not guaranteed
and and
and
you may cause excess
conflict inside the organization you're
trying to help
but then there are times when things
have gone too far
or a line has been crossed in your head
and you feel you just simply cannot
tolerate
things the way they are
and you've tried to use internal methods
to influence the situation but it hasn't
worked so you step out
and you speak out
and this has
happened recently
a marine corps lieutenant colonel
stewart sheller
spoke out about the disastrous
withdrawal from afghanistan
and he did this publicly
and without authorization from his chain
of command
and for that and for other actions that
he took he was relieved of his command
he was imprisoned court-martialed
punished
required to depart the marine corps
without retirement or benefits
which is a steep price to pay
to speak your mind on what you're seeing
and that is a hard decision to make
and it has consequences that will
reverberate for years
and lessons
hard lessons will be learned
and tonight we have a chance to learn
some of those lessons directly from the
source as
stuart sheller
former lieutenant colonel former united
states marine is here with us tonight to
discuss
what happened
stu
thanks for joining us
jaco thanks for having me that intro
gave me chills brother you laid that out
pretty awesome so i'm excited to be here
echo
i look forward to the conversation
let's let's start at the beginning just
to get some background on you as a human
so where'd you grow up
i grew up across the midwest my dad was
just an insurance salesman
worked his way up so we moved between
missouri kansas ohio i ended up going to
high school and college at the
university of cincinnati high school in
uh since 92 and then i moved out to
virginia i got an accounting degree at
the university was when you were in high
school what was was your mom working
mom was a stay-at-home mom so i've got
two brothers and a sister so four
siblings she was always there for us
driving us to soccer practice
i was a baseball and soccer player
any good yeah i was an all-state soccer
player i got a full ride played a couple
seasons
and yeah i was always a captain always a
leader
enjoyed competitive sports
did you make it to the state
championships
you know in ohio they had i don't know
if they still got it but they had a it
was called odp it was like olympic
development program so you'd have to try
out for these regional odp teams and i
made the team and i don't think we ever
won anything significant
and what position did you play i played
all over i mean i played club high
school college so
usually i was a skinny runner i was a
lot skinnier back in the day it was
probably you know 140 through high
school so i was usually outside halfback
sprinting but as i got a little more
muscle they put me back in the defense
and then when i got to college i was
again smaller so then they put me back
on the outside midfield
and we were you into school getting good
grades and all that yeah school's always
come pretty easy for me so i was always
on the honor roll i put in the work i
always got three five to four oh
yeah i mean you say if you put in the
work yeah
that's a big yeah yeah man
i mean i i like to have fun i like to
play sports and so school wasn't always
my focus but i knew getting a good
education and you know wanting to build
a good base was important so if i put in
the work of homework i'd always do well
but there were times where i just
wouldn't do it and then you know you pay
the consequences did you have interest
in the military growing up i didn't so
my grandfather landed at normandy
and i looked up to him a lot but after
his army service in world war ii he got
out was in the federal service
and his brother was in the fbi so that's
why i got my accounting degree they were
telling me get your accounting degree
and go in the fbi so i always loved
america i always wanted to serve
but no one in my immediate family other
than my grandfather was in the military
and so through high school all i knew
was i needed to go to college and get a
degree
and then a good job would be on the back
side and i was getting an accounting
degree and i thought maybe i'd go into
federal service but that was kind of my
thought process all the way through
school what year did you graduate high
school 2000 high school 2004 college so
september 11th happened when you were in
college that's right was it was what
kind of impact did that have on you yeah
good question so i was my sophomore
season of soccer and we had i was living
in the dorms and it was like a suite
where it was like four bedrooms and then
a living room and i remember sitting
there with my teammates watching it and
thinking
wow this is significant our lives are
going to change
but i don't know how this is going to
impact me
and then like i said i just went back to
i need to graduate college that's what
i'm supposed to do so even most of my
peers joined after september 11th and
that was like their motivation it was
different for me mine came a little bit
later so i saw september 11th it
impacted me like all americans but i
continued just going through school
still not even sure that i was going to
join the military at that time
so at what point did you
get serious about joining the military
so i graduated with an accounting degree
started working as an accountant and did
not enjoy working as an accountant and
it was 2004 and i was watching the tv
and i saw the marines moving through
fallujah and i thought hey we're going
to probably be at war for another 5-10
years i'd love an opportunity to go
represent america be a leader on the
edge of the empire
i've always like been competitive being
on teams and i just thought you know i
could go into the fbi any time
but this war may not always be going on
and i want the opportunity to serve my
country and so i called the marine
recruiter and started my my path so
really it was 2004 for me watching the
marines on tv that i was like i need to
get me some of that how long were you an
accountant for not long i i did it part
time as i was going through school and
then i did it for probably
nine months after i graduated
it didn't take long realizing that grunt
and fallujah looked better it did yeah
looking at spreadsheets
that's not for everybody uh so
so how long did the recruiting process
take in 2000 and so in 2004 you talked
to recruiter for the first time that's
right yeah i was quick um i talked to
him
probably in
september and the hardest part was
getting all the recommendations like you
need college professors recommendations
like university of cincinnati it was
like 1v300 like none of my instructors
knew me you know i had to like calm back
up like hey you don't know me but
can you fill this out you know and i
didn't accomplish anything at that point
in my life other than being a soccer
captain so like what did i have other
than a college degree and being on a
sports team and so you're supposed to
write all these accolades and
accomplishments and extracurricular and
so quite honestly when i fill out the
application i was like they're not going
to select me
but i submitted it and my strength was
athleticism so i smoked the pft
and that was easy for me and
within two months they selected me and i
shipped out in january
and where's marine corps ocs
it's in quantico
how's that
i think for some how'd that compare to
accounting i think for some people it's
a lot easier there's a lot of prior
enlisted guys that go through and i
didn't know anything about the military
i mean i didn't know the difference
between officers and enlisted i didn't
know the drill instructors were going to
scream at us i quite honestly thought
i'd show up and it would be like grown
man rules and you know here's the
challenge
figure it out
you know i just i don't know why that's
what i thought it would be and it just
it was not that and so you know the
drill instructors all start screaming at
you and they have you dump your bags and
they kick your stuff all over the parade
deck and i noticed when they were doing
that all my peers had their stuff in
ziploc bags because they expected it and
i'm like the one guy who's just lost so
my pens and my stuff are going
everywhere and of course on the last one
trying to collect it all up and so now
i've got like five drill instructors
circling me and i'm like fighting
through their shins to get the rest of
my stuff and so i tell this story just
to say it was illustrated from day one
that i was lost and then you know they
kind of kept coming hard at me but my
strength was like i said athleticism and
then relationships so i was able to
befriend all the guys around me
learn from them and you know i quickly
went we do peer evaluations there too so
like in the first period evaluation i
was at the bottom because i was lost but
by the third one i was like in the top
third right and so that meant a lot to
me so i was able to demonstrate to my
peers over the period of instruction
that like hey there might be more to
this guy than the lost little puppy we
saw on day one and so that was kind of
the story of my whole entry level
training i mean do they get rid of guys
that are consistently at the bottom of
the pure evaluations they do so the way
it works is they do a board system and
so there's three boards through ocs and
if you get essentially counselings so if
you're at the bottom they're going to
give you a counseling and once you get a
collection of them that you sit in front
of the kernel and have to justify why
you're there he's ultimately the one
that decides to cut you or not and then
also at ocs you can quit you can drop on
request and so it's actually pretty high
attrition so we started with 65 and i
think we got down to like 38
so i mean
but most of it is people that probably
shouldn't be there anyway quite honestly
um there are some some very talented
guys that
i had one guy that made it to the last
day the day before graduation this guy
graduated from the university of chicago
with a mathematics degree i remember him
very clearly because his last name was
sullivan and mine was sheller so i'm
standing right next to him in the racks
the whole time
the day before he's just like i don't
want a commission and i was like dude we
just went through like 10 weeks of the
craziest i was like he's and he said i
just wanted to see if i could do it and
so that's like the type of guy that you
want you know and so i was just blown
away by that and so then this guy made
it like he he had graduated for all
extensive purposes and just decided no
and so there are some that go through
all that and then
wave off but the vast majority that i
saw get a treated out probably needed to
be a treated out
and then you could roll from right right
from there to the basic school that's
right
and how how was that six months so what
they do is they just give you a baseline
of
infantry leadership skills they say it's
not screening technically they're only
supposed to screen at ocs you have to
keep in mind later in my career i worked
as an instructor at ocs and tbs and so i
understand like behind the scenes of
these two places intimately now too
but tbs is for all the open ground
contracts like myself where they
ultimately determine what your mos is
going to be your military occupational
specialty so it's a very critical spot
in terms of if you want to do something
specific you got to distinguish yourself
to be able to get that thing and you
learn a lot it's more of a college
atmosphere unlike ocs officer candidate
school or infantry officer course which
is like all field work tbs is like a lot
of classroom work you do some field
exercises just to kind of have a
baseline of tactical knowledge but it's
it's a lot of classroom stuff you said
open ground what is that
open ground contract
so when you come in you either come in
as a law contract an air contract law
like jag yes i'm kidding yep so law air
or ground those are the three
and so check
bottom line is when you're at tbs they
can't manipulate the law or air
contracts those are already pre-written
but everybody else they determine their
military occupational specialty at tbs
and how did you perform in tbs overall
i was the same thing i showed up i was
lost um a quick story on that so there's
a transition where you go from sleeves
down to sleeves up in the marine corps
you know
lost lieutenant chiller didn't know that
no one explained it to me at ocs and so
we show up and so the transition
happened to be just between the 10 days
we had between ocs and tbs so i show up
to check in and i'm the only one with my
sleeves down right and everyone's like
why don't you have your sleeves up and
i'm like well
all right so then again day one i'm the
one that doesn't know anything it was
the same thing pure evals you know i had
to like work my way up and i did
and um i was academically probably in
the bottom third just because all the
tests was just rogue memorization and i
tried to memorize it a lot of guys that
had
been in the marine corps before it was
just a little bit easier because they
knew the knowledge inherently
but my what what got me up was like
leadership evaluations are weighted
pretty heavily and i always did really
good on the leadership evaluations how
does that work was that like in a field
problem somebody watching you and
evaluating how you're doing yeah so the
grade breakdown at tbs is 40 leadership
30 academic and 30 physical and the
leadership is built upon different
exercises where you're evaluated by your
instructor so it's it's fed by
things that you do but still ultimately
it's subjective and even in the
leadership school what they do is so if
a platoon commander has like 50 guys
they have to rank you one through 50. so
they can't give everybody hundreds so to
make it fair there's actually an
algorithm where they have to stick it in
and so that's how you get a leadership
grade
what's a is it just a typical sort of
battlefield problem that they're putting
you on are you running an ambush are you
running a patrol or is it like uh what's
it like what do they grade you on yep so
some of them are leadership reaction
courses where it's like a complex not
complex but there's a problem that you
have to solve
and typically they're not solvable but
they're determining how you navigate the
situation that's not solvable there's
situations where you just you're the
patrol leader hey take your squad and go
attack this fire team on this hill and
they'll evaluate you based on that right
there's pure evaluations feed into it um
so there's there's quite a few probably
five or six different things that you do
mostly i think probably the heaviest
weight is the in the tree line you're a
squad leader so typically it comes down
to your squad leader you're doing
effects too you're doing pecs one which
stands for field exercise so they have
all these field exercises and they just
make you a leader of whatever you're
doing the defense build the defense
order and brief it and that's going to
be a big part of your leadership grade
are you guys shooting blanks at each
other yeah
we are are you using miles gear or some
equivalent we have we have miles it's
now called itez it's actually i test 2
now same thing but it doesn't work very
well in the tree line what it does do
though is it provides a graphical
overlay so if you're wanting to debrief
it like you can show hey there is the
lpop there was the support by fire so
quite honestly when we use it it's more
for after action purposes it doesn't it
just doesn't work very well in the tree
line so blanks is we found to be better
and then what did you what so where did
you graduate in the class when it came
time to graduate so the way tbs works is
they split it into thirds and so they do
that so that one mos isn't overloaded
with all the talent so
if you're in the top third you get your
first pick if you're in the top of the
second third you get the second pick if
you're in the top of the third third you
get the third pick so it became this
thing of everyone wanted to be like the
top of the third third right so you're
like you're playing the numbers game
so like i said i started in the bottom
third and i was like
but because of my leadership grades i
moved up to i think the top of the
second third i think it's where i ended
up and then you get to pick
so what'd you
pick i was i actually i wanted to be
infantry and at ocs i said to my drill
instructor i want to be an infantry
officer in fact when i was going through
the recruiting pipeline i my also even
told me that the guy does my recruiting
he's like i got an air contract and i
was like no i want to be on the ground
with a gun you know watching the tv
marines flu shows like i want to be on
the ground with a gun leader so at ocs
then i told them i was like i want to be
an infantry officer and they just were
like infantry officer scheller
you know
why why were they freaking out about
that i think they it's just all part of
the show it's a song and dance right
they just want to kind of knock you down
in fact some of them are still friends
with me um
but i at the time you just don't really
fully appreciate it and so those were
kind of still bouncing around my head so
when i got to tbs i actually had
infantry number three so i put combat
engineer and intel officer above it one
two and three mm-hmm and my they call
him spc staff platoon commander he's a
captain he was an amp trouser and he
just looked at me he's like sheller
you're going to be a [ __ ] infantry
officer that's
and i thought he was joking i was like
all right well yeah and then it came
time for selection i was waiting for him
to be like you know intel officer combat
engineer said infantry officer and i was
like sizing him up like you're joking
and he's like no i told you you're gonna
be never chopster
and you know looking back there is no
way i would have made it as long as i
did had i had any mls other than
infantry officer i just didn't know what
i didn't know then i mean it's by far
probably the best choice
and so in a lot of ways that guy shaped
my life and career and i was really
grateful that he did that
so then you get infantries and it's
often for your officer school that's
right and how long is that school three
months and how was that where was it
so i went through ocs january to march
of 005 tbs april to september 05 in ioc
september to december 05. so it was
rapid fire there a lot of times there's
because based on when schools pick up
people have two or three month breaks
but for me it just worked out where in
11 months from showing up to ocs i was
standing in front of my platoon so by
mid-december i was i was there and you
must have been getting guys that were
coming
fresh back from actually coming back
from fallujah that you watched on tv
that were your instructors it's better
than that when i showed up to 1818 was
the center battalion of that attack that
i watched on the tv and the first speech
i gave my platoon was like hey i'm your
new platoon commander half of them were
in sweats and so i took my platoon
sergeant aside after the fact i was like
hey why aren't they in the proper
uniform and goes sir they all have
doctor's notes because they all have
shrapnel still in their body from the
push through fools and that was like the
moment for me it was like oh my god like
this is real
i mean it's just like the way the world
hits you of the responsibility so yes it
was very real when i showed up to my
units
how was infantry officer school that is
probably one of the best schools bar
none i mean they really do a good job of
preparing you and i mean there's just
three months of intense
intense infantry training and i i really
felt prepared
showing up for my platoon i mean the
marine corps does a great job of putting
a product in for the platoon
in terms of officers now
are you going to get some that slip
through the cracks absolutely there is
no perfect system but i'll say
holistically from a guy that just wanted
to learn and wanted to be a leader they
did a really good job at preparing me so
are they setting up are you in a platoon
and you're basically taking turns as
leaders going out and running operations
that's right the whole time the whole
time
it's an in infantry officer of course
it's a lot more
current ttps as well whereas the basic
school is the fundamentals and green
side of building the defense very
conventional type stuff the the timeless
principles whereas infantry officer
course is like this is the new rco this
is the ied that's in ramadi right now uh
so on and so forth this is how we do
patrol in 5 and 25s right now
and so there's still a lot of timeless
stuff that goes on in ioc but it was
really nice to get a lot of current ttps
coming through that schoolhouse and then
the instructors too at ioc if you're a
captain and you're an instructor there
you're hand selected and most of those
guys go on to become generals quite
honestly so you get the creme de la
creme in terms of young captains that
have just come off their first tour like
the marine corps picks the best to go to
tbs and then from tbs they pick the best
out of tbs to go to ioc and so you
really just get great instructors like i
had brian shantosh
who was you know silver star i had
marcus mines who he got relieved
recently as a botanic commander but in
terms of like
deep thinker warfighter like there was
no better um so i just had i had a group
it's quite quite funny when you look at
my instructors a lot of them burnt out
like the chantashes in the mines
but i don't think i've ever ran into a
group of officers that maybe were more
outside the box thinkers and war
fighters than that instructor cadre that
i had there when you look back at that
time is there any lessons that stand out
to you like oh yeah that
that operation left a huge impact on me
i
i think just the mental toughness that
the instructors have pressed upon me
every single day is what i left with
i mean i walked away
with an impression that these infantry
officers are the real deal
they're war fighters and their and they
know their trade like it was very clear
to me that i had to step up my game and
i couldn't fake the funk because people
could see right through it and so i
think you know the ttps always change
but the the thirst for going and opening
the pub and making sure that you knew
more than everyone else
making sure that in those tough
situations you were the guy they were
looking to to have the direction to have
that mental toughness that they might
need are you guys doing live fire blanks
both
mostly live fire ioc is mostly live fire
obviously you're not shooting live fire
at each other so in the situations where
we did force on force it was blanks but
it was a ton of live fire did you learn
anything about like uh the amount of
pressure that you were gonna face did
they do a good job of simulating the the
pressure you're gonna face in combat
situations yeah i mean that was the
whole shtick
i mean there was even a couple times
where it may have even swung too far to
the other direction because
i remember one time we were getting
close to graduating and we had
gone from the desert of mojave up to the
mountains of bridgeport and then we were
coming off the mountains of bridgeport
and they stopped at some like rinky dink
casino just let us get drunk that was
like in the middle of nowhere where
probably no one would get in trouble
because it was literally in the middle
of nowhere right
well the director
this guy is still in the marine corps
regimental commander or
probably moved on by now
but he got so he was the major and he
just got hammered drunk and started
screaming at the lieutenants that they
weren't ready for combat right and that
was like one of the few times where like
you know i'm still young and the curtain
had been peeled back but i remember
thinking like i get it you got more
experiences than me but i'm about to
knock you the [ __ ] out like you know i
mean lieutenant the major like you just
don't talk to me like that like
and so
yes they did a very good job of
preparing us but sometimes i felt like
almost to the point where i was got a
little unprofessional at times you know
there's a line on how you treat a man
i'll rise to the occasion when given the
opportunity but i don't want to be
denigrated
and then from there
it's bad it's that's when you went to
one eight that's right yep so in fact uh
most of the guys because we graduated
right before christmas most of my fellow
students took christmas break and then
showed up in january one 8 was deploying
so fast that the battalion xo actually
came up to ioc and took me and my six
peers that were going one eight and said
i need you now we're going to ap hill
right after christmas and i want you
checked in with all your gear meet your
platoons and then you can take you know
a week for christmas and you're going to
show up and go to ap hill with us and so
that's what we did
and and you already talked about meeting
your platoon for the first time
yeah so there was that then i went into
the you know i didn't have a house so uh
my personal life i was dating my
my girlfriend at the time and i had
gotten engaged i got engaged that chris
so that week that i had off i actually
uh
i take that back i got engaged before i
went to ocs so
when i
she was working in richmond when i went
down to 1-8 she stayed in richmond and
so i was living in like this shitty
apartment um because i knew i was going
to deploy in six months my plan all
along was just do the first tour and
then go up to richmond and get out and
and be with my wife we got married in
between tbs and ioc in fact marcus mines
that guy was telling me about that was
such a good instructor the ioc they call
it combat endurance test this is like
their screening event it's like a
two-thirds of a marathon it's like 16
miles and then you got like little
stations like at4 do the at4 radio do
the radio and then about 10 miles in one
of the stations is ground fighting and
marcus mines was a college wrestler
and so you know you were just exhausted
at this point and this guy gets to just
beat up on tired little lieutenants
right like
good job dude so that's what he does and
i know i'm trying everything i can to
fight him and i thought i was doing
pretty good and i think because i was
doing pretty good he started getting a
little bit more violent and he elbowed
me in the eye and gave me a black eye
and i got married that weekend so in all
my wedding pictures i have this black
ice legendary um so yeah 1 8 sorry so ap
hill in january to march and then we
actually we went on deployment in june
of o6 and where was that deployment too
so at that time
everyone was going to iraq so that's all
we trained for that mark that january to
june was like we're going to iraq there
was no question about it but we're not
going to fly there we're going to get on
what we call
a mew marine expeditionary unit you get
on three navy ships and you sail over
there back in that day you know six it
was a it was a much bigger footprint
back then the naval
group had a submarine they had
destroyers i mean it was a whole
entourage back then but over time just
navy's degradation it's now just the
three ships
so we got on the ships we sailed across
the atlantic we went through the suez
which you know it's like a million a
ship so that just fiscally you know once
you cross the sewers and you're in
centcom like game on but when that
happened
israel and lebanon got into a conflict
this was in like june or july of the six
and so they actually turned us around
sent us back to the suez and then we did
a
neo non-combatant evacuation operation
and we took american citizens out of
beirut we sent a platoon in there to
secure the embassy and then we took him
to cyprus
and then we sat there and stared at
beirut for like six weeks like i just
did push-ups every morning like there's
beirut awesome
you know and all i wanted to do was go
to iraq and so then after like two
months of just staring at beirut we went
back across the suez got into kuwait
and uh they ended up saying you don't
have the legs for the deployment because
when you put people on a deployment
there's like eas cutoffs and to extend
that would have caused more trouble than
it was worth they did take our sniper
platoon out of that battalion and sent
them up north because at 806 it was such
a sniper fight we actually had
unfortunately a couple snipers were
killed so we ended up coming back from
the deployment and had a memorial for
these snipers and it was it was so weird
because most of us hadn't even gotten
into iraq and then we're at this
memorial
but that was that was the first
deployment
and then you so then you roll right into
another workup that's right so i mean we
went
so i got back in december and we
deployed to ramadi
by september so like six seven months
later and i
this is kind of this is a longer story
so i won't go in all of it but i ended
up having to go to winter mountain
leaders course from
uh january to march and then i got back
and we went to fort pickett all of april
so i was i mean i was only home and then
we ended up going to mojave viper was
what it was called back then which was a
two-month deal i mean i was only home
probably for about six weeks and i and i
my wife quit her job to come down and
live with me
in between that so we had bought a house
and it was like
yeah i guess i'll see you after the next
deployment because i am just not home
right and so
i'll skip forward the reason i didn't
get out after the second deployment is
just that
she quit her job and had came down you
know when i was in iraq and all just
worn out and she's like well what are
you going to do i said i want to get out
like that's the plan she's like well
what's the plan after them i don't know
we'll figure that out she's like we just
bought a house please take a
non-deployable so we can figure this out
but um so yeah personal life was was
tough at that time
so when you came home from that
deployment where you went to lebanon you
get back from that
and you immediately go into a workup but
on top of the workup you go to mountain
leader school you're just gone the whole
time your wife who would quit your job
is now
sitting in the house filled with boxes
that you never unpacked because you're a
bad husband i promised i would paint the
house and never painted it
i've done this drill before
i've definitely done that drill before i
i moved to virginia beach and i was
there for two years and in that time i
did two deployments and a workup so
my wife we never even took some stuff
out of the boxes in the house that we
bought so yeah i did that drill the
bathroom never got painted um neither
did anything else until until when until
we were getting ready to sell the house
then then i got a bunch of stuff done i
can beat that i've done move to move
where the stuff was still in the boxes
from the last move and the movers are
like well we need you to take it out of
the boxes because we can't use other
people's boxes i'm like you want me to
take all my stuff out of the boxes for
you to put in new boxes so yeah i bet
there is a mountain leaders course up at
bridgeport it is yeah and how was that
it was awesome so i didn't want to go
just because my wife had quitter driving
came down and i had limited time it was
this whole thing where i i put my name
in the hat because i didn't know my wife
was quitting so on the first appointment
i put my name in the hat when i came
back they're like you're not going
and then at the last second like after
my wife had quit and i promised to move
all her stuff out they're like okay
you're going i'm like what you know i
was like flipping tables how long was
that course
it was three months and so
it is very challenging because it's so
cold um so mentally it really takes a
toll but i'm a good skier i grew up
skiing in ski resorts around the midwest
and so that was fun and back then they
probably don't do this anymore back then
for weekends they gave us a 16 passenger
van and let us as the students have it
so we had a gunny who didn't drink and
he just drove us to tahoe or reno every
weekend i mean it was some of the
funnest weekends i've ever had in fact
the last time i came to san diego was on
that bridgeport trip so me and my buddy
took a flight to san diego and i had a
guy who had an apartment in the gaslamp
district and uh we had a good time yeah
and then you you go on deployment and
now you're working up you do you know
you're going to iraq this time yeah we
do and you know you're going straight to
iraq about taking a ship that's right
and
but this is now 2007.
seven but your workup is in 2006.
uh no the workup the workup was january
to okay july of those seven okay but
still do you know where you're going do
you know you're going to ramadi the
whole time yes
and so at that time still 2007 you start
your work up ramadi's still pretty
freaking hot at that point ramadi was
very hot in january 07 and there was a
thing called the al ambar awakening and
so it was almost like the sharp pivot
like
right as we were getting there and so
the unit that we ripped with two five i
mean they had just it was like gun fight
gun fight gun fight and then in the last
two months of their deployment it almost
like somebody just hit stop
and so it created a lot of weirdness for
us because it was like we were still
operating under ttps where it was like
gunfight gun fight gunfight and it just
it really wasn't that by the time we
showed up
so where were you where in ramadi were
you so i was a company xo now and
we
i was on the south
west corner i started a place called jss
iron
and
we had
like two platoon outposts so as a
company xo i was consolidating the
patrol rosters and
like the name of the game then was
always have patrols in the battle space
like what are we doing i just get them
out there right so just like just
saturate the battle space with presence
and so as xo a lot of my role was just
making sure that we had good perimeter
security of our positions that we had
all our gear and that the operational
plan i was like the op so if you will at
the company level
and
then about
three months into the deployment they
moved us because we were at that time
trying to move out of the city to
further outpost to allow the iraqi
police to have more
control and so we basically built a fob
from the ground up it was called
sua and this was all the way in the
south west out of the city now
and it was called sewa because it was
literally i think built by a sewer and
there was nothing there and you know
even though we had been in iraq since
what 03
it was like we had never been in iraq
before so it was like baby wipe showers
no chow hall i mean it was awful it was
bad
and so um we did that we finished the
deployment there
and what was the i know things had
settled down a lot when you when you had
patrols out in the city were they taking
any contact or was it yeah we had one
platoon that got in some context the
the problem then
it was almost i don't know i don't want
to say more dangerous but it was like
you'd get lulled into a false sense of
stability
and then there'd be a suicide vested
attack and you'd lose guys and so my
best friend so i i did the first
deployment in bravo company i was
playing commander so when we got back i
was still a platoon commander and bravo
company they moved me over to alpha
company to be the xo
so i still had a lot of good friends
that were platoon commanders in bravo
company one of them this guy's name was
dave borden used to
we used to make dinner he was a
pittsburgh steelers fan i was a bengals
fan so we'd always have like
rivalry games together with my wife
and
he got he responded to a sniper threat
and a suicide best came up to him guy
wearing a suicide vest and detonated it
and killed one of his marines and
blew dave up lost his leg and so like
there's just an example of you know i'm
sitting there for
two months with like nothing happening
and then i gotta listen on the radio to
my buddy being evacuated out lost a
marine
and then um and so yeah so we had one
platoon
um that all got combat action ribbons
from doing patrols and getting into
firefights but they didn't really kill a
lot of people
it was more that that deployment was
more just about like census patrol
stability
building [ __ ] and trying not to get
blown up i mean there was a
there was the adjacent battalion i might
get the units wrong i don't i think it
was two eight and one nine and they were
doing the rip towards the end of our
deployment and this is still a story
told in the marine corps
while they were sitting at the ecp a
huge so there's like two companies in
there because they were doing the rip a
huge dump truck blew through the ecp
with a bunch of explosives and all the
iraqis ran and these two young marines
stand at these people from different
units didn't know each other stood there
and killed the driver and got themselves
killed and all the iraqis were talking
about how brave the marines were and we
almost believed that they were probably
exaggerating it a little bit and then
after this huge explosion one of the
cameras even though it looked like it
was broken still had the footage and
they went back and pulled the footage
and it was exactly like they said these
two young marines standing at the ecp
knowing they were gonna die not knowing
each other
like in that instant realized what was
happening and saved everybody else on
that base so like that to me that story
almost describes what ramadi was when i
was there right like you
can be standing on that ecp for seven
months without a single thing and then
all of a sudden in a second there's a
dump truck flying at you and you know
you're about to die so
and so
for me as the xo
i was always it was like
i'm not exaggerating it was like 20 hour
work days
constantly
and you know you go back and you're
asking why were you working 20 hour work
days like
i can't put my finger on exactly what it
was it just seemed like there was always
something that required like immediate
attention and the iso container that i
lived in was with my company commander
and our one terp so it seemed like
people were waking us up like somebody
always needed one of the three of us
that was the stupidest move in hindsight
putting us three in the same sleeping
facility like it was so dumb
and so like when i came home
from ramadi
i mean i started having
chest pains like real chest physical
chest pains and i it took me a while to
kind of figure out that it was anxiety
and that i didn't experience anxiety
during the deployments like when you're
working 20-hour days and you're just go
go going and it hit me like once i tried
to chill out
um but i tell that just to say
i think i kind of was going so fast i
just kind of frayed some of the wires in
my brain there for a little bit it took
some while to work through some of that
so you get home you get home from that
deployment and then what's next
yeah so you know i had skipped forward
there earlier so i had planned on
getting out i didn't get along with my
battalion commander on that deployment
he was very
dictator-ish almost like verbally
mentally abusive i just didn't care for
him
i didn't i don't know if i even agreed
with the mission of ramadi like like i
said i joined because i wanted to be in
combat but i found myself as my company
commander would write the contracts and
as the xo i was what was known as the
pay agent i'd go to camp ramadi and
they'd filled my book bag with like 200
000 cash and i'd run around and just
give it to like these mafia figures and
i'm just thinking like is this what
we're doing like this just i don't know
if this counter-insurgency thing oh this
is what we're doing i was just like i
don't know what this concerns these
because all the generals are talking
about like how great it is but like even
as a young lieutenant like i had a lot
of questions i was so like that was that
was influential to me because i'm
thinking like there's got to be a more
effective way like these guys that i'm
giving the money to right now i don't
know if anyone else sees this but this
guy is not going to build stability here
in iraq this guy's going to take it he
might even make it worse for the local
iraqi
and so anyway i left
i would thought about getting out but my
wife's
very much wanted some stability i felt
like she deserved it
and so instead of getting out i took
school of infantry as a company
commander it was in north carolina i
didn't have to move
and the goal was to do three years there
and find get a master's get an mba and
then go on to the next thing
and when i got to the school of infantry
i was very busy i was go go go school of
infantry is funny because right then it
was iraq and all my instructors were
iraq veterans
and all their families are willing to
put their problems on the shelf when
you're at war but it's like they had an
expectation for their husband when he
got home that they would address some of
those problems and then those poor
instructors were working dark to dark
and it was like
every single one of them were going
through a divorce like up to like my
senior enlisted like every single one
like i was bringing in chaplains i was
bringing in workshops and so the biggest
struggle there was just the personalize
of my guys they all had drinking
problems they all had marriage problems
they were all working through their own
demons and then trying to teach
300 privates how to be infantrymen
without losing their cool you know not
flying off the handle
and so
that was kind of emotion more
emotionally draining than i thought it
would be
and i did it for about a year and a half
until
i right about then it was so i was at
soi from 08 to 10.
if you go back and look at the news
around 0-809 the comment on the marine
corps guy named conway was saying he
wanted to get the marine corps out of
iraq and into afghanistan so it was
right when they were trying to do the
pivot and i thought hey you know my
ramadi deployment
it wasn't the combat that i thought it
was going to be it was very emotionally
draining but it was
you know i wasn't shooting a gun all the
time so i was like i would love to get
into afghanistan and then maybe get out
and just have that experience
and so i contacted my monitor and i
found a deployment through an
organization called joint ied defeat
organization jaido and they he's like
there's a joint requirement for an
infantry captain he's like this is
perfect it'll get you there
you'll get every all the combat
experience that you want
and all you need is two years at soi not
three so after two i can cut your orders
if you get your command's endorsement we
can make this happen
so i went and talked to my boss and my
boss
didn't want me to do it he was very
reluctant he wanted me to be the opso or
the
h i company commander which is like the
senior bills there like he liked me were
you instructing at all when you were at
the soi or were you more
just like uh overall in management
position yeah so they you get 300
privates so
soi is in two camps so there's mct and
itb so all marine enlisted marines that
are not infantry go to mct and they get
it's it's evolving now with the new
force but back then they got like two
weeks of infantry training and itb you
got one month so it was essentially like
you're following school so the guys at
mct if you're gonna go be a motor t
driver go to mct for two weeks and then
you go to your moto t school itb they
just get longer training and their
infantry marines and they go under their
following unit and so again it it's
changing now it's i think it's up to
like 10 weeks for itb but back then it
was only four weeks and so
that's outstanding yeah it is it really
is
and so they got um
so we would get 300 privates and we
would divide them into four platoons the
platoon commanders were either staff
sergeants or sergeants and then each
platoon commander had two or three
instructors so you never had more than
three to four
for i don't know do the math like 75
guys
um so it's a lot the
instructor-to-student ratio was not good
and there was no other officers i had a
first sergeant and a gunny and then
there's the young captain and that was
the staff
so
you're not doing a lot of instruction
you're not seeing a lot of what's going
on i there were
most of the instruction
comes from they have a separate cadre of
instructors at the instructor group so
it's almost like the the staff that you
have is almost like facilitating and the
after hours and the watching and the the
day-to-day leadership now there's still
a lot of classes that we give out in the
field or once they get back to the house
and sometimes there's even like
scheduled platform instruction but most
of the platform instruction comes from
general support instructors so the
question was how much classes did i give
there were probably two or three
programmed company commander classes and
the rest was just impromptu hey you're
going on liberty this weekend i'm your
company commander
don't get in trouble i i was very lucky
in my career i i
was an instructor
which is a strong word to use when back
in the day
back in the day we used to add seal team
there was just instru there was there
was training inside each seal team so
like as an e5 i was teaching a bunch of
stuff and it really put me in a great
position because then you're you're
having to learn it better and then
you're teaching it and you're seeing how
it works and seeing the mistakes that
people made so i've always felt like i
learned a ton doing that and then later
in my career when i was running training
which
was our training was just freaking
outstanding and
but i got to again watch observe teach
and i learned so much when i was in
those positions and that's why i was
wondering if you were
you know kind of actively teaching and
what you got out of that you're 100
right the the people that learn the most
are the teachers
and because you can't fake the funk when
you're the teacher and you have to
there's you know five six seven hours of
prep for any one hour of instruction
that you get at a minimum and so 100
agree i've worked at a bunch of formal
school houses and we we learned that
abundantly the people that teach are
really the ones that learn in my opinion
yeah i think i learned
70 of what i ever learned in my life
while i was an e5
instructor cadre at seal team one
because i taught
that's the other thing i was like a
young single guy so it was what what
trip am i going on all of them i'm going
to teach diving i'm going to teach land
warfare i'm going to teach cqc mount
every teaching everything
and spec recon cool i'm going on the
spec recon trip so really just got to
teach everything and then you get to
watch and you're de facto detached from
what's happening so you watch it we used
to teach the
the new guys that came to seal team one
we would put them through their initial
course of training so then i'm watching
the young officers and i was just i was
an enlisted guy but now i'm watching
these young officers and seeing like oh
this guy is getting totally he's he's
spending all this time shooting his
weapon so no one's making any calls i'm
never gonna do that i'm never gonna make
that mistake and this guy over here is
imposing his plan on the rest of his
squad so they're all pissed at him i'm
not going to make that mistake so i got
to learn like i said i might even be
more than 70
from just being a young
e5 teaching at seal team one and then
also you had these senior guys that were
super knowledgeable
and they're teaching you that's just
freaking a good way to learn
um
but then you get picked up for this
jaydo billet yep
yeah that so the giado billet was
awesome i mean it was awesome so i had
no training so i mean you have heard my
story of all my training in terms of
ieds so an eod guy goes to school for
six to nine months depending on what
branch of service and what they did was
they put me in crystal city in a hilton
lobby conference room and then like had
a fake name for the conference shut and
locked the doors and they had some like
old ied maker and he gave us like a
crash course on how to make a circuit
essentially and then how the explosives
work and so we did that for three days
and then they shipped me downrange and
that was that
that i mean it was crazy when you think
about it and i ended up then you were
the id expert then i was the idea
i don't think they ever expected me to
be the idea expert they wanted eod is
obviously the ied expert but what the
billet was supposed to do
was be the infantry interface
to have enough knowledge of ieds but to
think like employment of infantry stuff
and connect the route clearance platoon
and the eod and then be able to
translate that into
whatever is important to the battalion
commander
so you get your three day of school
and
then you deploy right to afghanistan
that's right yep how was your how was
your wife on this whole scenario
my wife stoked was she so
dude
all right yeah
uh so we got because she's like oh
you're home that's right you kind of
have a normal job
it's almost like a night and i got her
pregnant so she was three months
pregnant and then i went to afghanistan
right um
i'll tell the story
because it just kind of illustrates the
stress on a military family so we were
going crib shopping she knows i'm going
to afghanistan the child again i was we
knew i was deploying when she was uh
three months
so we're going crypt shopping and we
went i'm like this is like the third
store like i hate shopping so we're in
like the third store and i see a crib
i'm like this one i want this one let's
get this one she's like i want to keep
looking around and i'm like well i'm
just going to stand here by this crib
that i like and you can keep walking
around and i'll be right here
and then she just broke down crying and
it had nothing was this the first baby
yeah was this the first kiss kid this is
a bad tackle i know
well that's what i'm telling a story
like it was my mistake people can learn
from it that's right you better go walk
around look at some freaking cribs dude
i know
and
and so that's what she she as she was
crying i'm just gonna stand here by this
one you go look around and come back
when you're ready i got it yeah i got it
is it building relationships you were
talking about earlier
so uh bad move on my part so
then we you know i had to usher her out
she's crying i felt bad we got in the
car and we drove home and it was like
one of those really awkward intense
situations we ended up buying the crib
online because we couldn't bring
ourselves to go look for a crib again
and um and then i deployed right so i i
tell that story just to say you know
i really wanted to go to afghanistan but
it comes these things come at a cost
right so i got a pregnant wife who's
trying to be very supportive she was
supportive of me staying and she was
even supportive of me going to
afghanistan
but it doesn't mean that it doesn't come
with some type of personal cost
so she's three months pregnant when you
leave for afghanistan how long is the
deployment to afghanistan a year
check and did you come home for the
birth of your kid like so you get when
it's a year you get it's too already too
long of an answer yeah
you get two weeks um but i missed i
missed the birth but i was able to come
home like
right as she like four days after the
birth so right after she got out of the
hospital so i did get two weeks with
them but i mean having two weeks with a
baby after you've been in just combat
every day for six months knowing you're
going back to that same place for
another six months
it was real hard to establish any
emotional connection because like
i mean that's just it was i would almost
have rather not gone home and be honest
with you because it like you're when
you're with them your mind's there when
you're there your mind's with them and
so yeah in some ways it was good but
other ways it was it was very hard
so you go on deployment who are you who
are you with
so i got to just like a solo operation
that's right it was just stu sheller
versus the taliban
um i got to bagram air base
and that's where gida's task force was
at so they called task force paladin in
afghanistan so we got to task force
paladin headquarters and they decided
because most marines are familiar with
southwest helmand and kandahar but they
didn't send me there they sent me to rc
east
to support the 101st army division
and so i got out the first unit i got to
was a battalion called 3187 and they
were in east paktika province and the
fab i got to was orgoon
and their company
fobs were all so dispersed that anytime
we had to take them logistics
it was like a one day road trip
throughout clarence platoon and eod and
anytime there was an eod response we had
to fly out on the fly line and it was
just i say that just say was very
distributed and like most people or
marines picture of afghanistan is just
like desert wasteland it was like the
rocky mountains where i was at i mean it
was
not what i was expecting i got up there
and i was like this is this is not the
desert
and so you could see pakistan from where
we were at it was just
it was uh cowboy country and then what
were you doing
um well i guess explain a little bit
more detail yeah so you get there's a
logistics supply that needs to go to
some outstation i'll illustrate with
with one more story from that time frame
so
one of the
company fobs hadn't been resupplied in a
while
and so they planned this
because in the
july august it was raining a lot and so
when it rains the the aircraft couldn't
fly the logistical supplies
and just because they
with all these jingle trucks it was
easier to move logistics so we took this
huge patrol so i went with eod and route
clearance patrol and all these logistics
trucks out to this company fob and
dropped it off and then when we got
there they said hey we've got this
platoon outpost over here on the border
near pakistan that just hasn't had
whatever in so many days like we really
need you guys to push this stuff out
here we here at the company fob don't
have the assets if you call back to the
battalion and they're like yeah if you
can that would be great
so we do so the next day then we go from
this company fob out to the platoon fob
and we left it like 8 a.m so how many
vehicles are you bringing with you so
you got just rough estimate route
clearance platoon is probably
a dozen you got the eod truck in there
you've got are you guys in mraps what
are you in what are the vehicles yeah
everyone's well it's mrap's and jail tvs
uh mix but they also had a lot of
logistic trucks were jingle trucks you
know what that is like a afghani flatbed
and then you've got the afghan national
security force they're all in their
f-150 pickup trucks and then you got
probably an infantry platoon or company
for extra security that maybe in just
humvees and so it's this so this is a
big convoy long collection of different
players damn
and so we drive through
to get to these things on the border
you there's not roads you're driving
through like the creek beds of the
mountain crevices
and we get to there at like let's call
it one or two o'clock in that so there's
15 vehicles 20 vehicles i'd say like 40.
40 vehicles to go out and resupply a
platoon yes which by the way has 40 guys
yes
so this is like correct
already you can see what this is like
crazy [ __ ] going on
yes okay so
40 so a 40 vehicle convoy
with every type of vehicles mad max
is driving out to resupply 40 dudes that
are out
on the edge of the world they were on
they were on the edge of the world yes
and so it's maybe like two o'clock when
we come out of the creek bed and this is
relevant to the story when we came out
of the creek bed there was like five
afghanis sitting there with like their
arms crossed staring at us and we're
like let's look at these nefarious
characters like what are these guys
gonna do
and nothing happened and we were all
kind of eyeing them and that's relevant
later so we go into the fob we drop all
the supplies off
it's like three o'clock and the call is
made like what do we do it's three
o'clock i mean it took us like do the
math eight to three to get here
do we want to go back or do we sleep
here tonight again 40 vehicles like this
little platoon outpost we're like
so probably a bad call i mean in
hindsight 2020 obviously was a bad call
but at the time it just made sense like
let's just go like you know get back
late we'll be all right
so when we start driving back now we're
going back into that creek bed where
those guys are so now it's nighttime no
it's like three o'clock okay when we
leave
it it gets dark soon
and so we're going back into this creek
bed and where those guys were standing
they had piled a bunch of rocks up to
the the creek bed
i'm like oh obviously this is going to
be an ambush
these guys piled a bunch of
rocks as a marking mechanism or as a
blocking mechanism great question okay
jack you know what i mean so we didn't
ask that very intelligent question we
just immediately assumed ambush
because that's that had happened it was
before so we're like all right these
guys are going to ambush us so you sit
there you got your eyes up and you're
looking around nothing happens and then
it's just like all right we'll let them
trigger the ambush like we're going to
go through it and we went through it and
nothing happened and then we just
didn't think through anything else and
we just started
going
so we get
now it's dark it's probably eight
o'clock
are the afghans
are you on night vision because i know
you're on that what the afghan too the
django trucks are on on
night vision i can't remember they were
so far back that if their lights were on
i didn't see it
check i can't remember it's a good
question i don't remember
so we
were it's now like eight or nine o'clock
it's dark and it started raining and i
can't it's hard to describe it's almost
as if somebody had broken a dam because
it wasn't like the creek bed started
slowly filling up it was almost like a
wave came down and hit the tires this is
like flash flood scenario out in the
desert
and so
with but it's still only at the tires
and the m-wraps and the jail tvs go
through it still pretty easily but then
we got the call on the radio that one of
the jingle trucks had gotten stuck
you know i can't even see it it's so far
back so i'm like all right and your job
in all this is like an observer or
you're not in charge of anything are you
i'm not in charge of anything but it's
weird because i outrank everything yeah
you know what i mean yeah
so you kind of are in charge
you're in charge
in a way yes right
and so
we stop
we're waiting for the jingle truck to
unmess itself and then all of a sudden
it was like another dam broke
and then the water hit right to our
grills like almost immediately and now
it's a situation where you can't just
get out of the car
and so
we
a little backstory we had killed taliban
members and taken their icoms and then
we keep this is on the same operation
this is on a previous one okay so i'm
telling the story so that you understand
we kept the icons in the patrol and we
put it on scan and when the taliban
started talking we'd catch it on the
scan then we'd hand it to the terp the
terp would interpret it and then we'd
pass over the radio whatever was being
said
so
when we were in the flash flood
now we're like worrying about the water
it comes across the radio like hey the
taliban sees that we're stuck in the
water and they're maneuvering to ambush
on us
okay yeah so now you're now you're in a
situation where it's like all right
what's your poison like because the
machine guns are all hooked up to the
trucks
but at a certain point you might drown
if you stay with the truck
you might drown just trying to get to
the shore
uh so it's like what do you do well we
all got up on the roofs of our trucks
and the waters kept coming up and
finally i was like i i'm gonna die from
drowning before i die getting shot with
a with the television so i'm gonna take
my chances so i slung my weapon
and i i was the first one to jump in i
jumped in i swam to shore current was
ripping but i'm a pretty good swimmer i
got over there and then i started making
rope bridges
so i tied some rope up to a tree i threw
it to the truck and then we started
having guys shimmying from the trucks
over to the shore and so then we passed
this down and all the trucks start doing
it well what happened was one of the
soldiers in the back
got on a rope bridge and he when he with
the weight of him when he got in the
water he panicked and he let go and he
didn't like clip in or anything and so
he rips down river so then the call
comes on the radio
hey we lost a soldier he's he's done
he's gone and this is an afghan soldier
i'm assuming no it's an american
american american soldier yep and the
afghan so he when he floats down river
one of the ansf see the ansf cm2 the
afghan national security force and so
they all started talking about how they
saw him
and he basically from our last vehicle
they spot him float by him so we know
he's still ripping down the river right
so now you're in a situation where
people start getting off the trucks we
know the taliban's maneuvering we've
just lost this guy down the river and
it's like oh this is getting messy real
quick this is a little beyond getting
messages
and so we try to call in air support um
you know because we've got a guy going
down the river all this stuff and they
deny it because it's raining and it's
it's red air so they say no
so i grab a bunch of guys and i'm like
come on follow me we're gonna go do a
patrol we're gonna try and find this guy
and it's
it's weird because they're not really my
guys so i gotta like play diplomat and
be like can i have some of your guys to
go do this but i had good relationships
so i was able to do that
and then it gets even weirder
so then the taliban passed over their
radio
that they had captured the american
soldier
so we got we picked up chatter that the
taliban has the american soldier and so
then we're all like man we got there's a
the acronym was dust one so like we got
a dust one situation so we call that
over the radio and previously they said
they wouldn't send aircraft but this
time now that because we're right there
on the board of pakistan when the
taliban's confirmed that they have one
of our men
they're like we're sending an air
support so they send this section of
apaches like immediately
and it was awesome i mean it was a
female section lead and i was listening
to her on the radio and she must have
killed like 20 dudes and she was just
like stoic like
killed five secondary explosion rpg he's
dead and like we were just watching her
just like sweep this hillside just
laying waste and um
i'll just fast forward to the end of
this story
what happened was
the soldier we ended up finding him the
next morning
he washed down river he drowned
and we ended up actually having we
thought he had been rigged with the
explosives
and so my eod tech put his bomb suit and
walked up to him in the river and cut
him down and when he floated down river
i actually caught them and pulled them
out
and i don't know if you've ever seen any
on this drown but like their stomach
expands and they get all these veins
and what had happened was the taliban
even though we were listening to them
they were monitoring the ansf radios
and when the ansf saw the soldier float
by they got on their radios the taliban
heard that and then they pat knowing
that we were listening to them passed
misinformation to get into our loop but
you know when i when i reflect back on
it
them doing that
triggered the apaches which ultimately
killed all of them so it's just one of
those situations that i mean
so you asked me like what did we do
like there's a story of like you know
you leave that and we're doing a
resupply for a platoon fob and you just
walk away from like that was there's
just a lot to unpack right there so did
the water eventually recede and the
vehicles were able to drive after that
the next morning it went down and we
were able to get all the vehicles out
because we brought
from external sources some wreckers to
help us pull stuff out
but they made us go up and down the
river looking for the soldiers rifle and
mvgs which we were going to find but we
spent probably until lunchtime the next
day just walking through the water
acting like we were going to find that
and finally somebody made the decision
to stop and then we got back on our
trucks and left
and what's the op temple like for you
so there's one mission that takes two
days three days what are you doing after
that so you know then you go back to the
company fob maybe spend a day reset and
then you drive back to the battalion fob
and then i involve myself in the
battalion battle rhythm the meetings
i continue to offer advice but every
time we're back at the battalion fob
anywhere in the battalion battle space
where an ied is found and my eod techs
fly out there i would go with them
i mean i can just keep going for stories
all day but we here's an example in that
same
space there was a helicopter that was
flying a
iso container of
machine guns out to one of the outposts
and it pickled it and which means it i
don't know what happened but they
decided to drop the iso container in the
middle of mountains so like hey we need
you to go up there check it out we want
to send eod because there might be
explosives in it so we fly up there we
get to the thing see if we can re-sling
load it we can't so we're like we're
just going to blow it up they're like no
you can't blow it up it's got machine
gun and stuff and we're like well it's
all burnt they're like it doesn't matter
you got to carry it out so i was
literally carrying like 250 cal
receivers like through the mountains
and it was all unusable but they didn't
want to leave it there and we were
supposed to fly out that night so i
didn't bring this is such a stupid move
i didn't bring like warming layers or
things for the next day
and of course because it took us so long
to carry all that stuff then it got dark
and then the aircraft didn't want to
land in the mountains so we had to spend
the night up there and i almost froze to
death i remember the only thing we had
was a body bag and i slept in the body
bag spooning another man so that i
wouldn't freeze to death
i mean that talk about in your head when
you're like in the body bag right
yeah as you're doing these operations
what are you what are your you know you
you mentioned that earlier when you're
in ramadi and you're handing out hun you
know thousands and hundreds of thousands
of dollars to various people
and you're starting to think
from a strategic perspective this
doesn't seem like maybe the greatest
idea in the world
when you've got 40 vehicles going out to
resupply 40 soldiers out in an out
station somewhere and the risks involved
and now you lose a soldier which is
freaking horrible
and now you're going to a mountaintop to
recover destroyed weapons because you're
not allowed to blow them in place
what is your what are your thoughts of
this now year how long you've been in
for at this point you're yeah so that
was eleven so seven six seven years so
so you've got a little bit more maturity
as a as a human and as a military
officer
are you starting to wonder what the
hell's going on
absolutely i mean you just outline
really good points right there i think
what ate me the most
when i took that 40 vehicles to that
40-man platoon i could see pakistan i
could see their bases i could see where
they shot mortars at us from and we
couldn't do anything
so when you talk about strategic
problems like does america really want
to win this war like i can see the
[ __ ] home base right over there like
why can't i go over there and kill them
and so i mean when i look back at the
afghan war i can't wrap my brain around
that if i was going to put service
members lives at risk i'm going to do
whatever it takes to win the war or i'm
not going to be there but there was just
a ton of things that we didn't do from a
foreign policy standpoint to allow the
service members to win the war it's
criminal almost and so yes standing
there at the border of pakistan i
remember looking at their home bases and
just thinking this is crazy
and then how long you this deployment is
a one-year deployment yeah and in the
middle of it you go home you miss the
birth of your son
first son
but you show up what two three days but
after he's born that's right
and now you're going through this
transition of
one day you're sitting there waiting to
get blown up by an ied and the next day
now you're sitting uh looking at the new
crib holding your son yeah
and
i i agree i know it's horrible to say
but like the mindset of
not wanting to be a part of that kind of
while you're still trying to work i
never you know the in the in the navy we
go on six months maybe seven months
maybe eight month deployments and i
never went home from one of them uh you
know the army
would send guys home because they'd be
on deployment god bless them for 12
months 14 months 16 months they it was
mandatory that they would send guys home
and even even like battalion commanders
would go home for two weeks
to give guys a break and give guys rest
and let them see their families
but you go home it's it's two weeks at
home
i mean
are you able to adapt at all or is it
just how i just just send me back
i think
maybe if your home life was consistent
there might be some utility in it
but when my home life had changed so
much like my wife couldn't even stay in
her house because she had just had a kid
she was bedridden
she was at her mom's you know there i
i'm not able to take care of her she's
having to have her mom take care of her
so i've gotta for my two east go stay at
my mother-in-law's
i've got a new kid
i mean it's just it was like i was
living somebody else's life when i came
home and
again all you can think about is the
constant combat you're going to go back
to and it was just a lot
you roll back over there and you just
maintain this op tempo for the year that
you're there that's right i mean
i ended up random
operations
tag along on random operations well i
moved
probably in october november-ish i moved
out of eastern pakico and moved into a
province called ghazni there was a
district called andar and so we built a
base from the ground up called andar
fabandar and i moved to support one 187
so i went from 3187 to 1187
and
back then so this is in 2010 the polish
had run that ao for like two or three
years and the polish don't fire unless
it's in self-defense don't do anything
aggressively so that's why they put
americans there and so again you know
we've been at war for at eight years at
that point and it was almost like
uncharted territory in the middle of
afghanistan ghazni is like the economic
center you know maybe outside of kabul
and so for you know it's similar to
ramadi where like i went to sua we've
been in ramadi for six years and all of
a sudden i'm using baby wipes and we
have no infrastructure and it's like
it's like we've never been there before
i felt this at the same thing happened
when i went to fobandar like we're
building it from the ground up and
it's even the the kinetic threat it was
like no one had done anything
and that that area was different than
the first one i described because the
first one was much more distributed it
was like these long day patrols that one
was very much like day in day out day in
day out like foot patrol from the base
or route clearance to just that adjacent
little block over there
and so so you were out you actually
moved to that out station to that fob
yes and how big was that fob how many
people were there was it like a company
was it battalion
headquarters but all their companies
were in company outpost so i mean there
was only probably 200 people in it did
they have a company there that they were
utilizing for that ao
that was running out operations for them
yeah so i understand the question i
think i think potentially one of the
companies was in the battalion fob
because obviously somebody owned that
battle space
i can't remember
and and so then you're there
and you're doing the same thing you're
going out on patrol whoever's going out
on patrol trying to capture the id
information sending that id information
back up the chain of command that's
right yeah so
um a couple more stories just to
illustrate that kind of what i did one
time one of the companies
found a house full of it looked like
propane tanks but it was like aluminum
tanks filled with powder found like
a hundred of them just didn't know what
it was and so they threw them all in a
well and then they took a picture of it
put on a storyboard
wait a second
so the platoon's out on patrol yep they
find a hundred aluminum tanks filled
with random powder yep they don't know
what to do with it so they chuck them in
a well that's exactly right they did not
misstate that okay and
then you know young captain sheller is
reviewing the storyboards because i felt
like that was the right thing to do
again i didn't have a boss so it was
like you know i was in general support
as battalion but i really could have
done nothing had i chose to
but every day went through all the
storyboards went through all the stick
acts went through all the stuff like was
really trying to hide myself that story
right there like i could i could just
imagine looking at one of my platoon
creators like okay tell me that again
yeah yeah wait so what'd you do yeah
wait what was in them and you hucked
them all in the well and they were so
ignorant they then took a picture of it
and put it in their store
usually when you do something that like
raises an eyebrow and you're like i
don't know if i should have done that
you don't include it on the screen
so they put it in the storyboard it's
one of those things where i i bet
a platoon commander can articulate you
know what we didn't know what to do we
couldn't carry him out we didn't want
the enemy to use them the well was deep
made the call sir yeah it's like okay
roger that i'm having a tough time
briefing this off the chain of command
but i got your back
so it turns out it was aluminum powder
so in that ao so in the first one i was
at it was all potassium chlorate there
was a match factory in pakistan so all
the ieds were potassium chlorate but in
this new ao they used uh
aluminum powder with ammonium nitrate so
we called that anal actually and so what
they had in those containers was
aluminum powder that they would mix with
the fertilizer to make the ieds and so i
identified it i pulled the patrol
together we went out
and when we got into the house
like
i'm literally holding this powerpoint
print out of the storyboard it's got a
picture of the house and it's got a well
in it and i'm like walking around
there's no well i'm like are we in the
right house it's kind of dark what had
happened is they the taliban had come
behind the soldiers and put like plywood
over the well and then covered it in
dirt to basically hide the aluminum
powder that the soldiers had all thrown
in there and so it took me like 45
minutes but finally i was like no no
this is the house like this it has to be
like right here and then you just start
kicking it you're like oh you know
so then we we ended up
disposing of all of that um so there's
one example of like what does a counter
id team leader do they're you know just
caught that and then the other thing i
usually did was i i walked the rails so
as an infantry guy i would pull probably
six or seven soldiers out of the route
clearance and on known routes where we
found a lot of aed's the the time i got
my bronze star
where we were walking down a route i'm
on one side they're on another side and
you could see guys messing with
something on the road like
probably an id right so you know we try
to close the distance this guy runs away
circles around he's getting chased by my
other guys on the other side of the
street and so he crosses the street
while i'm running out the other side and
i was like one of those things where you
like you both come around a corner and
you're like face to face and you both
just like try and pick up your guns and
somehow you both miss each other from
like three feet away
and uh you know got behind a corner
killed a couple guys and some machine
gun fire went off and there was at one
point where like i just kept chasing
people and i found myself like 200
meters away from even like the guys i
was with maybe like you know a half
kilometer away from the patrol and then
like panic started to sit and like oh
[ __ ] like i'm kind of separated here
um but i was able to i was able to bring
the infantry up and link up and they got
some mortars downrange and the takeaway
from the story is we uncovered seven
ieds on the throughout that day and
rendered them all safe and they were
trying to do a complex ambush right with
all those ieds and we were able to push
push them off
but like there's an example of like
great tactical success
like what the [ __ ] did that do in terms
of the overall picture like i'm not
really sure like on the tactical level i
mean that was was an awesome play that
we ran
but i mean i just got so many examples
of that and then then i start studying
the operational strategic levels that
i'm like what was the connection to what
we're trying to do like why why are they
still coming from pakistan
you know what is my political leaders
doing like are we trying to get rid of
the taliban or are we going after al
qaeda
yeah so many questions
so you wrap up that deployment yep you
come home
how's coming home now that you're home
home
yeah so when i got home from afghanistan
again i was going to get out
but they offered me formal schools
called expedition warfare school it's
captain a major school it's a year and
i just thought
man this deployment has taken a lot out
of me emotionally spiritually like a
year in school with a bunch of other
warfighters of my peer group probably
really good for me rather than trying to
jump into the corporate world and so i
took the ews job instead of getting out
which was in quantico
you owe time after that that's right
right look at you
one step ahead of me yeah so
the catch to that is there's a two-year
requirement on the back side so by
taking the ews job i then was required
to go serve two more years as a company
commander and this is going to get you
out to what how many years
really it gets me out to a career is
what it does but yeah it takes me about
10 or 11 years yeah 10 or 11 years at
which point a lot of guys say
hey i'm i've only got you know what is
it you look at it only got eight more
years and really how many tours is that
plus one of that last tour is a twilight
tour so i really only have six years so
people start negotiating and
rationalizing staying in even if maybe
it's not 100 what they're into at the
time that's right which is
which is interesting because you're
almost the whole time you've been saying
you were going to get out you're going
to get out you're going to get out
which is weird i never i actually never
thought i was ever going to get out
until i got out the whole time i thought
i was staying in forever i'm like oh i'm
gonna do 50 years so watch this
and then it was very abrupt for me you
know when i was like oh you know what
i'm actually going to get out and so i
always thought i was going to stay in
which is
which was
i guess it was very easy for my
decision-making process because i was
like hey what do you guys need me to do
yeah what do you want me to do let me go
to that call go to that whatever let's
go
um but you were always kind of
i think
it was like we started with the
beginning of my story this i never had
ambitions to go in the military and this
was never what i thought i would end up
doing the reason i continued to stay in
is because i found a lot of purpose in
being a marine officer and i truly
enjoyed it truly enjoyed being around
the service members so it's one of those
things where i guess my
self-image was never to be a career
military officer but i continued doing
it because i found fulfillment in it
yeah and there's also something
beneficial about someone that's not
considering that oh i want to be you
know that's i always joke about the seal
teams because in the seal teams if you
ask a seal officer a young seal officer
why they came in the seal teams they
answer what's what what what job do you
want to do i guarantee what they're
going to say is i want to be a platoon
commander i want to be a seo platoon
commander that's the that's which by the
way is like three years into your career
yeah
you ask an army officer what they want
to do a lot of them will say oh i want
to be a battalion commander i want to be
a brigade commander i want to be a
division commander that's actually in
their head seal officers do not have
that in their head most seal officers
don't have that in their head and
there's something that's kind of
nice about someone that's in the army
that just says hey you know i want to be
i i hey i want i don't have this big
aspirations of being a general or a
colonel they just want to go and do the
job there's some benefits to it there's
also some detractions to it because once
guys in the seal teams get done with
that platoon commander tour a lot of
them go okay you know i did that and
we've in the seal teams tried to extend
the operational tour a little bit longer
you know you can you can extend it you
can go a little bit longer and still do
work but eventually
it's going to dry up for you and you
don't get to be a battalion commander
you could be still team commander but
that's
not the same as a battalion commander
it's really not the same as a brigade
commander cool jobs
but it's not what people come in for so
the fact that you were sort of
always thinking maybe i'll get out means
to me in a positive way you weren't
trying to maneuver for your career
because there's a lot of guys that oh
yeah here's
oh i need to do this billet i'm trying
to get this award
i'm trying to get this deployment so i
can get promoted there are some people
that that's what's driving their careers
and it's it's never it's it's horrible
to see it's horrible to see what they do
and there's guys in the certainly guys
in the seal teams that are like that
that's their that did have the goal of a
platoon commander is just a step just a
stepping stone because what they really
want to do is they really want to make
admiral or whatever
same thing can happen in the army as
well same thing can happen in the marine
corps but for you you're kind of like
playing it by ear yeah
which means you're not making decisions
based on hey i'm going to look out for
my career which is a good thing
in many cases
yeah that
i see that in marshall too what you're
the problem you described with guys
doing what they want to do because a lot
of marstock guys want to be a team
leader
or you know want to be a company
commander company commander is kind of
the pinnacle where they then bleed off
all the talent because the company
commander at marshall is a major and
then they don't stick around to be the
battalion commanders that they need them
to do
but i also see the general infantry a
lot of the counter to what you just said
there's a lot of guys that come in that
have aspirations for being a battalion
commander have aspirations for being a
general
and they're you know
you kind of alluded to it there may be
some positives to that in terms of big
thinking and
you know
speaking good about the system and
figuring out how to navigate the system
correctly but
i honestly think the focus should always
be on the service member and what's best
for them and i understand as a leader
i've been doing this for 17 years the
responsibility to the organization
versus the responsibility to the service
members so i'm not saying in all
respects a leader always should just be
looking out for the service member but i
think when you get focused on how to
navigate your career it does cloud your
perspective on how to strike that
balance
so
nonetheless you take the deal and you go
okay i'm gonna go expeditionary warfare
school
and
then i'm gonna owe them two more years
so that's gonna put you at 11 years 12
years your wife's probably like cool at
least this my guy might be gone a lot
but at least he's got a job and it's
we're getting a paycheck yeah i had my
so as soon as i got back from
afghanistan
she got pregnant with a second kid so my
two older boys are 14 and a half months
apart so that's like you know before
afghanistan and then like first time
getting home from afghanistan and then
it was like i said very quickly within
nine months of being home from
afghanistan went from like no kids to
two kids you know so it was
life was changing
um and then we waited another couple
years and had my third son in between my
next two deployments so how was
expeditionary warfare school i liked it
um you know the anxiety that i had after
ramadi came back full fledged after
afghanistan started having different
symptoms started having like
face numbness and my eye my vision
started getting blurred and everyone
wanted to lump it into ptsd which i knew
i wasn't struggling with ptsd i didn't
have like bad dreams i didn't feel bad
about anything i did i just had like
tony soprano-ish like real physical
symptoms
and it just people then the buzz phrase
was ptsd and i just don't think people
understood what anxiety was and i just
had to work through that and so
i don't think i really understand
what what you're talking about yeah so
ptsd would be like oh i'm having trouble
sleeping yeah i'm
uh the hyper alert and all that yeah
what's the anxiety piece what's what's
going on with this
and is it physiological yeah it's both
so it's part hereditary it's part you
know nurture nature so also it's part
experience so i think the simplest way
to just say it is once your fight or
flight gets burnt enough your brain
starts producing
different chemicals that it may not be
if you're not under high stress all the
time and for me it just took a while to
recalibrate i had to get into yoga i had
to get into meditation i had to you know
the best remedy is working out so if you
can work out stay healthy and stay fit
but the problem is a lot of guys after
these deployments fall into the false
trap of like alcohol and alcohol is one
of those things where you know it can
suppress some of those anxiety or things
for a little bit but what they don't
realize is it comes back twice as worse
the next day
and so ews was one of those like false
hopes for me where i was like coming
back i hadn't been drinking for a year
and i was like drinking beer and you
know i feel good at night and the next
day i'd be like oh why do i feel so
horrible
uh i was also getting older too right
i'm in my 30s now i'm not in my 20s
anymore and so i think part of it was
just learning my body learning all the
physical reactions that took place in
the deployment and not allowing myself
to just be bend in a ptsd category that
may not apply to me even though that's
what i think everyone wants to label
someone when they get back from
something like what i had gone through
and uh you know it all worked out i
figured it out but it just took me
reading a lot of books and talking to a
lot of people probably more than i
needed to to navigate it
let me ask you this
so if you get these like anxiety type
situation
and it's caused from
some traumatic situation that you've
been through and now this is post the
traumatic situation isn't it like
what you're talking about well i don't
understand the difference between ptsd
yeah and what you're talking about
anxiety
i think
the the way i
distinguish it is ptsd
from what i've learned from the
psychologist
typically manifests itself
in to
guilt shame
emotional struggling with some of the
things that you went through that
may have a psychological and physical
impact on you
anxiety to me think of it like you're
about to do public speaking and everyone
has butterflies but like a severe case
of anxiety is almost like debilitating
right
and those physical manifestations
may not necessarily be tied to a trauma
they may just be tied to
the way like you said physiologically or
built or it may just be because you have
experienced so many things that your
brain is producing chemicals in an
imbalanced manner
no i'm not a doctor so somebody needs to
check the stats on this but i can tell
you having talked to many psychologists
there is a
in the whatever that manual is
a
major differences between the two okay
and then you as you're working out and
you're doing yoga
and you start to get through that did
that come after you went through the
drinking phase of trying to get through
it
i always worked out
sometimes i worked out and drank
so i had to just get through the
drinking thing yeah and then just focus
on working out yeah
and and this is all happening while
you're at
ews yeah correct
learn anything good at ews what are you
learning at ews aws is a little bit more
like operational level
yeah i went to
two formal schools well i went to
command staff later as a major command
of staff is very varsity level treats
you like an adult here's all the reading
go read it and we'll talk about it like
it was adult ews is like somewhere
between you're still like in the basic
training pipeline and you're like
getting close to an adult but we're not
really sure yet so it's you're treated
as such and there are a bunch of
captains that aren't careers yet that
probably need to be treated like that
but i think it gets generalized too much
so there were times where i was like i'm
a professional i've been to like
multiple wars like don't [ __ ] talk to
me like that
um what's ews it stands for
expeditionary warfare school
it's like the captain to major pme
so you don't have to go to the resident
but you have to do the school so there's
like box of books where you can get sent
the books and get credit for it that way
there's seminars where you can go to
like night school for it so every
captain has to go through it to become a
major but they select the top ones to go
to the resident one-year course
and so that's where you got selected for
that's right so your career is going
pretty good at this point actually it
was an indicator that i was on the right
track
[Music]
uh
and
what what you this is a one year school
where are you going at the end of that
where'd you go on the end of that
i went to third battalion second marines
as a company commander so as a
headquarters company commander
where
we our deployment was another mew was 10
months get on ships
sail around the ocean and be ready to
respond
and as a headquarters company commander
on a mew i had i had like a recon
platoon i had an engineer platoon and
then i had like all the supporting
establishments in the battalion this was
kind of an eclectic group of individuals
and then they also used me as like the
future operations planner if you will so
as the opposite was on the ship they'd
send me to like egypt or they'd send me
to wherever to do the planning for
whatever that bilateral was
um and so that was my my 10-month
deployment there that was a 10-month
deployment yeah it was long shipboard
deployment it was like right after the
uh
the libya thing
um and the benghazi thing and like the
and because of that thing
the mew deployments had gotten like
backed up something happened that messed
up the deployment cycle because of that
operation and so to like fill the gap my
deployment was 10 months because they
always want overlap and so i don't
remember fully understand why it
happened but they told us from the very
beginning like this is gonna be a long
one boys and that was a shipboard
deployment it was so you're living on a
ship
which is good times
yeah
something
but that's weird that's almost like for
me you know because i came in before the
war
that's like a normal deployment that we
did back then i did two deployments with
the marines on the args out here on the
west coast but it was like hey
sail around
go to wherever we're going like i went
to egypt i went to oman went to these
various random places
and did whatever exercises we're doing
people getting spun up about whatever
they're getting spun up about you
probably did you create any powerpoint
briefs for you on that
you know i did
uh
all right so that's another deployment
and what comes after that
so then i get back and they actually i
was still a captain
and they tried to make me the operations
officer
and i did the battalion operation
yeah so
i had actually gotten the top company
commander fitness report as the
headquarters company commander which is
kind of rare so i think it just speaks
to my potential commander really liked
me thought highly of me and so he tried
to make me the operations officer and i
wasn't selected that year so i was going
to be in zone the next year and
regiment's like
brother we got like five majors sitting
on the deck up here that need key billet
like if you're gonna make a captain
that's not even selected like we're
going to give you a major
and so he came back to me and was like
hey like this is what happened so you're
not going to beat up so
what do you want to do do you want to
stay in the battalion and you've already
done your company commander tour
or do you want to
go somewhere else and
in my community headquarters company
commander is like one of those weird
ones where
you can hide somebody there
and so it's not always the best guy
and so like
in terms of street cred in my community
i didn't want people to think i was just
a headquarters company commander right
and so i was like you know i gotta no
i'm gonna stay here and i'm gonna go be
the weapons company they offer me
weapons company which is like the
probably the best company commander
usually in battalions
and so that's what i did so i was a
weapons company commander for the next
year and a half did you do a deployment
how's that i did so we did a deployment
it's called a unit deployment program so
we went to okinawa and we're the purpose
of it strategically is to be involved in
the war plan if north korea were to be
do something but all we really do is try
to prevent our marines from getting
drunk and getting into fights and then
we'll take them into you know japan and
go into tokyo we went into south korea
and that's a six-month deployment six
months what number deployment was that
for you five
including when one of those was a
one-year deployment yeah one was a year
one was ten abroad mahdi was seven and
then the first meet was six and the udp
was six so it all comes out to i mean
about four years
yeah all the stuff up
and then after that
what's next yeah what's crazy too is
with all those deployments like that was
middle of 15. then i got promoted the
major and i never deployed again so
quite honestly all of that it was
through my captain time which is even
what made it crazier and so i got
promoted to major and the monitor at the
time was actually the company commander
of my platoon commander buddy who got
blown up in ramadi guy's name was eric
clark and i knew him real well
and so we had a special relationship and
he had selected me for a place called
ppno it's like plans policies and orders
and in the marine corps it's a very
prestigious bullet so it's like one of
those builds that if you do well you can
go on to be a general officer so if
you're a guy that is playing the deep
game like you described like that's the
job you want
and i uh
at this point i had decided it was going
to be a career so after 3-2 i was like
this is i'm going to go to 20.
and i just had no desire to sit in a
basement cubicle in the pentagon and you
know design the new helmet or whatever i
was going to do right i just i couldn't
do it
and like you said earlier like i loved
teaching and i loved idealistic young
officer so i asked him if i could go to
the basic school
and he obliged because he had a lot of
people that wanted to do people you know
so he cut me orders to basic school and
i tell that story about i knew him
because it's not usually that easy to
just talk to your monitor and say no i
don't want that i want this and have it
work out but in that situation it did
and so he got me orders to the basic
school and i got back from the udp
in july of 15 and then i off cycle moved
in october 15 and i bring that up just
to say my kids now i have three kids at
this point
they're the two older ones are in school
and i didn't want to pull them out of
school so i actually geo batched so just
again more more distance right so get
back from that deployment and then i
went and was living in a condo in dc
and driving back to north carolina on
the weekends for nine months uh until
the following summer when i moved him up
all right so the basic school this time
you're on the other side watching people
go through was that a good to me that
sounds like a good learning experience
seeing people
how they react
from a leadership perspective and from a
psychological perspective that's right
yeah
and it's great the basic school is all
taught by officers so unlike school of
infantry where the instructor is
primarily enlisted
at the basic school the primary
instructor is the officer so even as a
major they sent me through a pretty good
training regimen and i
had to get qualified
to train every single thing so it's like
they have a different qualification for
each subject that you attempt to teach
and so they do a really good job there
i got to be the operations officer a
company commander and the war fighting
director operations officer and war
fighting director typically lieutenant
colonel billets but i just got the
opportunity because
at that time they didn't have the
lieutenant colonels and they chose me to
fill both of those bills at different
times and my three-year tour there so i
mean i really got a great run out of
that
and
not to kind of like focus on this you
haven't really brought it up a little
bit but just to kind of because where
this story ends up your your career is
like going really well at this point
yeah i mean as you mentioned you were
the number one platoon commander i
didn't mention it as the weapons company
commander i got submitted for the
leftwich award which is you know best
company commander in the marine corps i
didn't win obviously but just to have my
battalion commander submit me up through
the regiment division for that was an
honor and then yeah at the basic school
like the monitor tried to send me to
ppno
and gave me exactly what i wanted at the
basic school then when i got to the
basic school they made me the opso and
you know i said brand new major which is
a normally lieutenant colonel's billet
and then i did a company commander tour
and then it was a new co and then the
new ceo hand chose me to be the
warfighting director and so yeah i mean
i think i was very competitive now
what were your fit reps looking like
this whole time i'm all top i mean if we
want to skip forward the
judge in my case was like i've never
seen a record so example exemplary it
also high marked so there's an impartial
guy that looked at my reports and it's
like this is the best i've ever seen
so but you got to keep in mind like i
said earlier at the basic school the
best captains went to tbs or went to ioc
and when i was at tbs i was a major the
best of majors don't always go to tbs
the best captains do and so i was a
little off track and when i the reason
is coming out of ramadi number one i
didn't have anyone that used to be in
the military there's a lot of people in
the military today i think nepotism is
is prevalent like a general sons or at
least had a regimental father and they
they don't get a free pass but they
understand the key billets that they
need to go to
and they understand the relationships
that need to be harnessed and
and developed and so these small
advantages in the beginning turn into
bigger advantages over time so i guess
my point is when i went to school of
infantry as a young captain that didn't
help me at all as a professional and
probably even going to afghanistan on an
ia billet where i didn't get a report
from a marine didn't help me at all in
terms of career progression so like that
whole three years where it was very
important to probably separate yourself
i just didn't do
it but
going into my 3-2 company commander time
because all those experiences i had
did make me a very effective leader i
was able to really shine as a company
commander and those reports were really
what stood me uh it got me starting to
separate from the pack and then as a
major at the basic school again same
thing so in those six years it was like
i think that's when people started
looking at my record and saying who's
this guy but
i think most of my other peers that
there's a lot of peers that i have that
are i will admit much better than me i
mean smarter than me more talented
and so i look at some of some of my
peers and i'm just always impressed and
i just always you know want to aspire to
be like some of these guys but some of
those guys were put on tracks early
kind of hand selected for things early
that i just don't think anyone knew
about me until later in my career
probably similar stories to ocs and tbs
right i show up on day one and i'm lost
and by the end people are like look at
this guy maybe he's not as lost as we
thought he was i think my career is
almost the same story
so
you get done with
being the uh basic school instructor and
then it's off to
then it's then is that when you went to
command and staff college yep yeah and
now so now you're in it to win it oh
yeah yeah because once i got to the base
of school i was in it to win it so
yep i went to command staff got selected
for school it was nice because i was
already up in quantico is it hard to get
selected for school
uh it's not it there's two things one
you got to be
competitive
so probably in the top
40 percent which really isn't that much
but top 40 and then you have to be the
timing testament
right so
there's a couple factors in place not
always the best sometimes it's just
about timing and how how long is this
how long you go there for
commander steps a year
a solid year and as again now you're
going to owe time but you don't care at
this point because you're that's right
you're doing a career your wife's on
board with doing a career she loves the
stability she's looking at retirement
yep she's like we're set for life shares
of that i think we're over selling it
now but yeah she i mean our kids are all
in school now so my youngest is now in
preschool three kids in school they're
still young enough that we want some
stability and my goal actually was to go
back to lejeune so when i was there as a
captain i had bought a 50-acre piece of
timberland that i've got four-wheelers
and stuff that i keep on it and then we
still own my house in jacksonville so i
had two properties still in north
carolina when we were up in d.c and so
my goal after command staff was to get
back to north carolina and just remain
there until retirement and so that was
kind of my play
now some of the
some of the more conflicted thoughts you
had when you were
in ramadi when you were in afghanistan
are those are you are you kind of just
dealing with those as in like hey that's
the way it is sometimes you know i can
do a good job i can try and mitigate
that stuff in the future
when you're at command and staff college
and you're talking about now
more senior level strategic level things
are are you having
considerations around those things are
you having discussions around those
things do you feel like
you've sort of accepted that that's the
way the system works and there's some
benefits to it and there's some
negatives to it and you can as you get
more senior you can focus more on the
benefits
where are you at mentally
yeah it's a great question so at command
staff you can do a master's i think it's
part of the curriculum now when i went
through as a student it was like an
option you didn't have to do it because
it required extra classes and a thesis
to write on your own time so some people
just wanted the down time chose not to
do it but i wanted the masters i wanted
to
challenge myself
and most instructors there
implore almost like they drive you
towards
writing something about like the
tactical level
small squad unit level like insightful
novel idea i wanted to write about
foreign diplomacy and how it was broken
and i had been working on the small
tactical level at the basic school for
three years i was the warfighting
director for the year previous like
there's probably no one more qualified
to write some type of thesis 20 page
paper easily on how to do that but it
just it didn't interest me
um and so i was reaching for foreign
diplomacy and my my instructors my phds
told me like every year there's somebody
that comes in here and talks about how
the goldwater nichols act needs to be
revamped and it's just the same old
stuff and you know my counter that was
like well it hasn't [ __ ] been fixed
yet has it and that there's probably
nothing more important when we're still
losing wars
and so despite all the pushback on it i
wrote you're only supposed to write 20
pages then the parameters of the paper
were
minimum of 20 papers no more than 80
pages so i wrote 65 pages like i just
couldn't stop writing
and i gave it to my instructors and they
just handed it back to me like
immediately like 65 pages i'm not going
to read this it's like
you guys assign 80 pages a night of
reading 80 pages a night
i just spent
months
writing this and you can't even give me
the time to say these parts of your
paper don't add value like you won't
even like read it
they like make it less and so that's
what i was up against it was like i felt
like as an officer i wanted to be
challenged academically
and i just
i didn't get it from the phds so i did i
made it 30 pages got my master's
checking the box and then nobody ever
read the paper again
did you learn any good information at
command and staff collins was it helpful
oh yeah i i do think the
you know like if you're saying
command of staff college is their value
in it a hundred percent
the real question is could it be better
and yeah it absolutely could be better
but it's always easier to find ways for
it to be better i think from like 30
years ago what they have now is you know
world's better than what we used to have
like they have small groups they
facilitate good discussions they really
challenged my thinking on the wars i
mean we went back
to like frederick the great and prussia
all the way through napoleon and civil
war and modern day and i think they did
a really good job but they didn't go in
too deep onto anything and they
challenged me and
like
henry kissinger's book diplomacy i had
never opened it up and they really
pulled a lot out of there that
challenged me and i'm a i believe in
realism and i don't think american
foreign diplomacy has really gotten to
that level
and it's been like explored a little bit
but again they just exposed me to a lot
i think it's really incumbent upon the
student that once they're exposed to
something to then really get the
education on their own and it takes
independence to be able to do that if
you just go through the motions of what
the school asks you'll get very little
out of it
was there any
paradigm shifts in your thought while
you were there
no
my problem in an education system is
i always start to get a little
frustrated because there's like a system
to the education system and like if you
haven't figured out about me i'd like to
challenge things and at a certain point
people don't want to hear it and you're
just becoming a pain in the ass and so
there's like a line that you it's
different for every person every boss
i've ever had says i want honest
feedback
what does that mean to you like well i
guess i'll find out through trial and
error of giving you honest feedback and
there's gonna be a certain point where
i'm gonna either read through your face
or through your emotion or what you're
saying to me that
i've gone too far and now i'm starting
to annoy you and then that's when you
know you got to back off and so i always
find myself in the small group
discussions like i can dominate any
conversation with my opinions but
there's a time where you got to read the
room and understand
you need to be a passive listener and so
that was probably my struggle with it i
just felt like some of my views
went counter to what they were trying to
teach and if i was to get too aggressive
with it it seemed to be
counterproductive advice discussed and
so
a lot of it has to do with
counterinsurgency you know same thing
with ews like i just
the way you win
the way you fight a counter or the way
you fight an insurgency is to not get
involved in an insurgency and that
requires deeper thought on the operation
on strategic levels and we've just
celebrated these generals for the last
20 years that have wrote the small words
manuals or reinvented the small world
awards manuals and counterinsurgency
manuals and
there's a time and place where we as
military tacticians need to understand
how to do it absolutely 100 agree read
all the books got it
but to just continue to engage them for
multiple decades without like real
metrics of effectiveness or exit
strategies afghanistan withdrawal is
just the perfect example i mean there
couldn't be a better historical example
of how that was just terribly executed
and it's just a symptom of a much larger
problem and so a lot of these opinions i
had in commanded staff solidified
through my paper
and you know i left there i told the
story about me handing the paper to the
phds because that's just another example
of like no one really cared
they were there to expose you to the
things that they were exposed to but
they didn't look at like where stu
sheller was academically and say how do
we get stu sheller individually to be
more challenged and developed to where
we need him to be and maybe they don't
have the bandwidth to do it but
you know you look at the great military
minds of history like klossowitz he had
a guy named scharnhorst that was a
military professional that sat there and
ch and knew where kosowitz was met him
there and then challenged him
specifically
and i just
i i sometimes wished i had that
so you wrap up at that school yeah and
then where are you off to
and then i so i told the story if i
wanted to get back to north carolina so
i told my monitor different monitor now
don't have a relationship with this guy
and so i had seen him on two road shows
which is like yearly the monitors go
around and you get an opportunity to
shape what your desires are going to be
when you're a mover so i told them two
years previous i want north carolina i
don't care i want north carolina and no
one really wants camp lejeune so usually
when you say camp lejeune it's like all
right you got it but you know i had
spent my whole time in camp lejeune and
quantico i'd never been out to the west
coast or anywhere else and so i knew
there was a chance that the marine corps
was going to start to say no brother you
you've uh homesteaded too long so then i
saw him the year before same thing and
so he said all right i'll tell you what
to do if it's not north carolina i'll
call you and keep in mind i didn't do my
opso billet based on that story i told
and as a major you got to do what's
called key billet and for an infantry
officer that's opso or exo so coming out
of command staff they're like you have
to be an exo to remain competitive
and so
i mean everybody got orders in like
january february march i mean i got to
like the end of march we're talking like
you're gonna move in june and i still
haven't even talked to this guy like all
the school registration is in like
january my wife's asking me every day
and i'm like you know i don't know what
to tell you babe i don't so i finally
because i know this guy's real busy
but finally i just broke down and i
called him and i was like hey man in a
march everyone in my
command of staff class has orders except
for me you told me you would call me if
it wasn't campbell's june so i'm
assuming i'm still going to campbell
june can you confirm
and
he he's like no campaign's filled he's
like but good news we have availability
in 29 palms or san diego and i'll let
you pick and so i got off the phone with
them i didn't know exactly where i was i
was at panera
and i was still writing my master's
thesis at the time so i was like i used
to go to panera and just write and so
i'm sitting in panera just mad
and i'm thinking about all the property
i got north carolina and how like i've
been telling my wife it would be north
carolina for two years now
and so i wrote them an email
email's a little bit easier for me to
not be as emotional because i can kind
of edit it and i wrote
but i want to put in writing i was like
hey man i'm putting this in writing for
you
i'm going to forgo key billet there's
got to be a sexual assault officer or
some other thing in north carolina that
you can give me
it's in writing make it happen then i
hit send and like
you know you gotta understand like how
how scary it is to do something like
that because like i essentially said my
career is over in the panera
but i wanted north carolina and so then
he called me back and said this is what
he said he said
i got your email i'm going to give you
exactly what you want and then he hung
up oh my god i was like oh man yeah i'm
going to be the sexual assault officer
second reign division like this is and
i'm gonna have to go back and look at
all my peers and they're all gonna talk
about where they're going to be
battalion exos or battalion officers or
wherever and i'm gonna have to tell them
what crap job i just got because of what
i did to myself
and i know what he did then because the
monitor has two responsibilities he's
got a responsibility to the marine corps
he's a responsibility to you as a person
and the monitor's job responsibility
marine corps is to keep competitive
officers competitive so then he went he
didn't know me from adam so after that
he went through my record and as he was
going through my record he probably came
to the realization like [ __ ] this guy is
pretty good if i bury him in a staff job
and second marine division then i end
his career and he had a responsibility
to keep me competitive but he also knew
that i had like dug my heels in and i
wasn't going to california without like
probably you know screaming at the top
of the mountain so he was in like a
no-win situation and so that's how i
ended up at marshall so he wasn't
advertising a marshal support battalion
xo
and he had that kind of hidden on the
shelf and so he called me back and he
was like hey
i've got a martial support battalion xo
they're actually asking for infantry
officers i haven't made it public it's
not really key bill but maybe it is
kinda because it's still a battalion exo
it's just not an infantry battalion he's
like would you be interested in that i
was like [ __ ] yeah north carolina
marshall [ __ ]
this all worked out thank you you know
and so that's how it work how it
happened and so i took second
marines uh
mrsb marine raider support battalion is
what it's called and so the way it works
is marsoc's got three battalions
and then they have three support
battalions the sport battalions have
their logistics common intel marines
and they basically just do a six-month
workup just in the mrsb and then they
aggregate them to the mrb
unit and then they do six more months
and then so it's like a full year of
training and then they deploy as that
aggregate team and i was the exo so all
i did was facilitate the teams on their
timeline but i was only there for a year
so quite honestly i only saw like one
full cycle and then other cycles in the
state of did you go on deployment or no
so while i was there
because they only have three battalion
commanders and so they actually the
battalion commanders of the support
battalions are actually badged marsaak
guys
and so they have in that sense they have
six battalion commanders so marshawk has
at any time six commands selected
battalion commanders and so the sodif
downrange they have a cycle of when
those guys go down there and control
command that unit they actually while i
was the exo took my battalion commander
to be in charge of the sort of so he
doesn't deploy with the battalion he
only deploys with like maybe five key
guys and then some other people from
across the regiment
so i was essentially the battalion
commander for majority of the time while
i was back there but i never deployed so
i just sat uh
there in
courthouse bay with my battalion uh his
battalion but i was acting
and uh it was really it was a good time
i i truly enjoyed it and why was that
building on me a year
because i got selected lieutenant
colonel yeah good question i would have
stayed in marshall until they
until i retired to be quite honest with
you but i got selected to lieutenant
colonel and i actually went to the
manpower meetings it was acting ceo and
exo and in the manpower meetings so like
i heard it from the horse's mouth
they're like we don't have we're filled
up with lieutenant colonels that are
badge like we can't accept any
non-badged lieutenant colonel so you
gots to go a kid
so
i was your wife during that year was
everything going cool there yeah
everything she's kind of stoked she's in
north carolina it's all government i
thought we hit a we had a sweet spot
then you know once we got back to north
carolina we were in our house it was
familiar territory
i was happy with my job at marsoc kids
are in school now so she has a little
bit of like sanity yeah i mean it was
good things were good on the home phone
at that point and so then what happens
when you make lieutenant colonel where
do they send you so i mean i knew i got
i found out i got selected in like
october so i'd only been at marshall for
like three months so like within three
months of taking the job i was looking
for the next job
and so i had some buddies that were up
in division second marine division which
was still local and so i basically
started putting out feelers and i was
like hey i'm gonna have to move
um
i'll take a staff job up there got my xo
job being the exo edelmar soccer support
battalion so i don't need key bill
anymore i don't think so if you could if
you guys could take me i'd appreciate it
and then i finished the year at marsoc
and that in that spring
the chief of staff of mars sox an 06
talked to the chief of staff of the
division who's in 06 the chief of staff
both of those gentlemen are generalists
now actually
and between that conversation they
decided to make me the sixth marines
opso so i don't know how that shook out
i don't know if it was because they just
thought i was that talented or because i
hadn't done key billet in an infantry
battalion that they wanted to give me
the regimental up so
to make me more take care of you that's
right
but either way it was i mean pretty
important job there's only two regiments
in the division and to be the operations
officer of one of them was a big deal so
then i did that for the next year before
i was selected to battalion command and
then what happened once you got
battalion command
so i got selected battalion command
um
shortly after getting to the regimental
opposite job so but the regimental
opposite job just to paint a picture
going into the the story we're about to
tell
i mean it was
the marshlaw job was awesome fulfilling
manageable hours
good work the regimental opso job
was like
20-hour days we spent two months at an
itx which is in the mojave desert where
it is just expected that like i don't
eat i have tobacco and i just drink
energy drinks like it's almost like i'm
looked down upon if that's not how i
conduct myself
and it just it took a lot out of me and
my boss was uh
not very appreciative most of the time
and
i got into some like this was kind of at
the point of my career where i started
really pushing back so like as a as a
first lieutenant as a exo and ramadi
with my battalion commander was kind of
verbally and even at times physically
abusive like i just kind of took it and
in my head was like this is wrong but as
a regimental also as a 40 year old man
if you start telling me like i'm gonna
i'm gonna what do you say
i'm gonna [ __ ] fillet you i'm gonna
[ __ ] cut you in half that's what i'm
like [ __ ]
[ __ ] come bring it what [ __ ] you
gonna do you know like these are the
conversations we would have and it's and
it's like dangerous right
because and i had these with multiple
06's like i don't know what it is about
regimental commanders but they they just
felt like they could talk to me like
like i was a piece of [ __ ]
and i just got to a place in my life in
my career where i just wouldn't be
talked to like that
and so it created this unhealthy tension
and
then when i would push back on some of
these conversations
you would think that after like a couple
days
it would actually um
be like a steam release but it almost
like
it almost was like seen as a threat
and it would almost increase the
pressure where then they would come back
and want to like reassert dominance
which would then want to cause me to
like
reassert like [ __ ] you
and it just became unhealthy
and everyone could see it
and so you just got to understand that
like that's what i came out of after a
year of just being overworked to like
almost like fist fighting a couple times
and then going into my battalion
commander seat
so you you're you're having clashes with
regimental commanders oh yeah
and
as this is happening are you thinking
yourself like all right maybe i need to
maneuver a little bit here you know i
spent a bunch of time at expeditionary
warfare school learning about maneuver
warfare and not to attack you know
hardened positions head on and here i am
engaging in verbal battles with
my boss yeah
do you ever think like well
maybe i should have taken a different
tact
when you have certain people with
certain expectations
so you can just
not
push back and try and do an artful way
but
that type of person is still going to
expect you to work 22 hour days and be
unappreciative when you do get to bust
your ass to get the product to them and
then the follow-up question once you
finally get that product is where's the
next product
and so
sometimes you get a boss
that just no matter what you do whether
it's soft diplomacy or whether it's
verbal fighting back
you're just not going to probably change
that person so the point you're making
is like pick your battles and be smart
but the point i'm making is at a certain
point in my life
i just refuse to be talked to a certain
way
and so
was that good for my career was that
good for my mental health i don't know
but like i just i i kind of solidified
who i was what i was capable of and how
i was going to be treated and that was
the bottom line and i had certain values
that i wasn't going to compromise and i
didn't care what it meant for my career
and i've got a couple stories where like
i basically tried to throw my career
away a couple of times because i was
like this is important to me like this
is important to me and you know you can
think about what you want but um
when i think something is right like i
just don't back away from it what kind
of thing would you put your kind of you
know draw a line in the sand on
in terms of like regimental commander
where you're like you know what i'm done
with this
there was one time
she's
there's one time at itx until
the culminating event and honor in the
service for the marine corps at itx is
called um
mwx maneuver warfare exercise and one
regiment gets two battalions and then
one battalion given hyper-enabled
capabilities it's free force on force
now it's supposed to be free but there's
a lot of rules that almost drive the
skiba maneuver but i mean it's the
closest thing we get in terms of like i
is a regiment alapso with two battalions
with lar with artillery
and with a whole exercise force that
determines who got killed and who
doesn't
get to build a plan but it's also like
high stress and so most of our coc was
back in the rear
where i thought
the regimental commander should have
been
but
old
generals and kernels think that they
need to lead from the front
and in doing so actually probably put a
lot more risk on the system and they're
not comfortable sitting back in a coc
that has probably the capabilities that
we need and so what that caused was him
coming out with a forward capability
that i had
and in signature management when you're
trying to like not turn on certain
things or turn them on in a systematic
way that disguises your
digital footprint
he and i were sitting in this tiny
little coc that i made out of the back
of a trailer it was just one of those
situations where i got like six
computers i'm typing on all of them i'm
trying to control battalion opposites
different lar platoons
i'm trying to worry about my signature
management and he's yelling at me to do
something and i'm like quickly answering
him while trying to do all these
different things
and there was just like one situation
where he snapped started screaming in
front of everyone
and i looked at him
and that was a situation like you're
talking about maneuver warfare i didn't
say anything i just walked out
it was just like i'm we're gonna fight
so i walked out
i took like 20 minutes and i came back
in and then he like
hey up so like maybe you should just
chill and get some sleep and that was
his way of saying like maybe he went too
far like trying to offer me some sleep
and of course i'm stubborn i'm like no i
don't need to sleep i'm just fine and
like i talked to some of my guys after
because he did it in front of everyone a
couple of my guys were like i can't
believe you didn't hit him like i can't
believe you had the balls to just walk
away like i wouldn't have done that
so there were times but i guess i'm just
giving those examples because it's like
man this just you're exhausting me
so it is what it is
so you're in that job as the regimental
operations officer when the afghan
afghanistan withdrawal goes down is that
right yeah so
another relevant piece of the story is
eighth marines we used to have three
regiments in the division and eighth
marines dissolved and so 1 8 actually
got aggregated into six marines so i was
the regimental officer that took one
eight re-aggregated them and then made
sure they had all the supplies that they
needed to go out on deployment so like i
was working with their obsolete exo like
on the daily and so i was very familiar
with that unit that got on the mu that
ultimately responded
to the kabul incident and so that's part
of it right 1-8 was my first unit if you
remember where my best friend got who
with the suicide vest and then 1-8 was
in my regiment that i was so kind of man
trained and equipped as much as the
higher headquarters does to send them
out on that deployment and then i was
selected to botanic command so in june i
went over to school of infantry and took
advantage training battalion and that
was in like mid-june
and you know august 26 is when the uh
the s fest attack occurred so in june
you were going to school you went to
school no i i commanded a battalion that
was out of school so it's called
advanced infantry training battalion and
so that's the place where
if you want to go through sniper school
if you want to go through advanced squad
leader school if you want to go through
advanced mortar school all the advanced
infantry schools are housed under that
instructor cadre of the battalion that i
commanded
all right
so
just to get into afghanistan a little
bit uh just to get well not to get into
a little bit but to put some context
around it
um
february 2020
trump makes a conditional deal with the
taliban that we're gonna withdraw
um
september 2020
the afghan government the taliban hold
talks in doha the talks break down
they're not making any progress but
america still continues this withdrawal
plan
february 2021
u.s and afghan government officials
warn
everyone that the taliban is not abiding
with the agreements they're they're
doing offensive things they're making
maneuvers
april 14th biden changes the withdrawal
deadline
from may 1st to september 11th
which is
let's face it you don't pick the the
date september 11th out of a hat there's
a you know some kind of a symbolic
gesture
that that the bite administrated
administration wanted which is hey
september 11th this thing's over
um
april 15th
the taliban says up you guys reneged on
what you said you were going to do you
said you're out by may now you're saying
september we're going to take counter
measures
may the taliban starts doing exactly
what they said they start increasing
attacks
increasing in scale their attacks
increasing in frequency their attacks
june 6th
u.s contractors begin pulling out
and when you pull out contractors
now the afghan forces and this is where
you really start to see some of the
problems that are going to occur because
when you pull out these american
contractors that take care of gear and
supply
replacement gear
all of a sudden all that's gone
and this includes you know vehicles
planes
aircraft drones helicopters everything
that they've got all of a sudden they
don't have the the capacity or the
know-how to keep it
to keep it running
july 1st
america closes
bagram airfield like in a
really
kind of weird way of just leaving
just just kind of up and left without
telling anyone didn't even tell the
afghan that that was going to happen the
afghan government thought was going to
happen just did it
and by the way
the bagram bagram is a you know is a
great logistics hub it's a big massive
airfield it's well supplied well
supported
how long has it been there for 20 years
yeah you know 19 years some incredible
amount of time so it's in a relatively
secure area fully functional and we just
kind of
leave it
july 8th biden says he's confident in
the ability of the afghan military to
ward off
the the taliban and fight the taliban
and defeat the taliban
july 23rd the taliban starts applying
pressure
uh president ghani
is now
not just asking but
almost a begging for us assistance
there's a conversation that that biden
had with ghani
and he's he says and i don't know if
i'll nail the quote but he's saying that
the perception is in the world that
things aren't going well
and biden says hey whether it's going
well or not we need to project a
different picture
august 6th
taliban takes full control of their
first province
and now this is in direct violation of
what they said they would do
in the deal with america
august 15th
taliban takes control of bagram
no resistance they just walk in there
they there's a prison there they free a
bunch of these high-level prisoners from
various anti-afghan government and
anti-american forces
they also enter kabul that day president
ghani flees
bails out apparently with a bunch of
money and i will never get over the
irony of the fact that president ghani
was this kind of academic individual
that had written a book called fixing
failed states a framework for rebuilding
a fractured world
and in that book
he uses examples like oregon
the state of oregon in america a first
world country and that's how he talks
about using examples of how to how to
fix failed states
august 16th biden comes on and says yeah
well you know
the the afghan military's falling apart
because they're cowards
and their political leaders are weak
weak
august 17th allied governments
complaining about
the lack of communication and
coordination from america so they start
their own rescue missions and we're
hearing a lot about that august 23rd the
director of the cia
william burns meets with the taliban
leader
with uh baradar to discuss the
evacuation
so we're trying to sort of
save what we can
piece together some kind of an
extraction plan
that's on august 23rd on august 26th
suicide attack
11 marines
one soldier one navy corpsman
killed
the marines apparently
they
there are reports that they knew that
this attack was coming there's even some
sources
that say that the marines
were saying hey we got to put up a
stronger perimeter we got to push the
perimeter out and they got told no
so that happens that's on august 26th
and that is when
you
reach the point where
you felt you needed to speak up about
that
yeah a couple other
events in that timeline from at least my
perspective
so as the service members were watching
all that play out real time in social
media
on the news everybody was getting very
upset rightfully so
and so one day you didn't mention was 17
or 18 august the commandant of the
marine corps released a white letter
that said hey i know a lot of you are
struggling
but i want you to know your sacrifices
were worth it and if you're struggling
go see the therapist
you can google it that's i just
summarized the whole thing
and i read that and thought this guy
doesn't get it
the reason people are upset is not
because they think their sacrifices
aren't worth it the reason they're upset
is because the leaders have failed in
this withdrawal and that is undermining
all their sacrifices and he didn't
address that at all and a hand wave of
going to the therapist is not good
enough
so you gotta understand like i read that
and it just
just kind of started eating at me
and then the other thing that you have
to know
is i've heard
from the generals without naming names
i've heard this story many times
following vietnam
there's two commandants commandant
wilson and commandant barrow
and what they did was and this is what's
told today
fix the service
they focused on cleaning up the draft
class the drug users and making sure
they could fix the failures from vietnam
never does anyone talk about the
operational strategic failures that
occurred at the general officer level at
vietnam
that never got addressed and what's
happening right now
in the at least the marine corps with
the shift in the tactical focus and i
understand i think there's actually a
lot of utility in the new forced design
but what we didn't do was take a knee
and address the operational and
strategic failures that happened in our
last two decades and i feel like the
narrative is going to be told again that
the generals had to fix the service
because this current g-watt generation
isn't capable of fighting on the
tactical level so i'm struggling with
these two problems like senior
leadership isn't addressing the failures
and i and i have a couple examples of
that
and then yes that takes us to august
26th i'm sitting in my office as a
battalion commander and i am literally
i have people texting me pictures of the
marines that had gotten killed so like
i'm finding out like within minutes
that's the gossip on the inside
the company commander for all the
marines that got killed was one of my
spcs at tbs meaning he was one of the
one of the platoon commanders
not an sbc he was he was a teacher at
tbs i knew jeff ball real well
and i knew some of the marines so and i
have this long history with one eighth
so there's there was no one where it was
more personal to than i felt like myself
in that moment
and so
i sat there in my chair
and thought
i don't think senior leaders get it i
don't think they understand the failures
all these conversations about how well
it's going
i can't think in military history at
least over the last 30 or 40 years where
there has been such a monumental failure
and not one person has acknowledged it
and i just knew with certainty that
following this event no one was gonna be
held accountable like i had enough
experience and education to be able to
foresee they're gonna wash right past
this
and you can't make up for the lives that
were lost
but we can absolutely get ahead and
prevent the next
stupid decision by starting to hold
people accountable and i felt the way to
do that was through
what i wanted to be just the one video
like i did not plan it to be anything
other than that i thought i'll make one
video i'll explain some of the things
that i think they should have done and
i'm going to demand accountability
because that's what i think we deserve
because we're missing it and so that was
what led to that first video and even
after i made it like i i articulate in
that first video that i knew i was
potentially going to lose my job my
retirement my family's stability like
obviously i had thought through that i
articulated it in the video and even
after i made the video i didn't post it
right away i went back to my house and
was like pacing
deciding whether or not to hit post
because i knew as soon as i hit the
button it was going to change the
trajectory of my life but again i had
spent my whole adult life experiencing
studying thinking
living this
and i just got to a place where i didn't
think anyone else was going to say it i
felt the need to say it
videos about
i think it's about four and a half
minutes long that's right something like
that um you're in your camis so that's
something so you're you're definitely um
not shying away from who you are
you
you know you stay you but you say in the
video you've been in the marine corps
for 17 years um and one thing that i
reflected when i saw the video for the
first time
is i thought to myself oh you know your
entire career we've been at war you know
i spent
more than half my career we weren't at
war you know we was in the 90s the dry
years but i'm thinking man this guy's
been in the marine corps for 17 years
the marine corps and america has been at
war for that entire time you as you
mentioned you said you know you got a
lot to lose
you knew what could happen you knew you
were risking your battalion command
you know family stability the whole nine
yards
you bring up that letter from the from
the commandant that he wrote
and
[Music]
you know you mentioned did anyone throw
their rank on the table and say we
shouldn't give up bagram
which again you know going back to the
the silent five which is what mcmaster
called the the joint chiefs of staff
that worked for lbj
and you can even hear you know that i
read in the beginning of guys that
reflected back and said
i should have said something i should
have i should have stood up
um
you talk about the fact that
the people that died dying in vain if we
don't
uh
you say you said if we don't own up and
say we did not do this well in the end
and
you know i always look at that when
someone gets wounded or killed in combat
at a at a bare minimum at a bare minimum
at least we go okay we can learn from
what happened in this situation we can
pass it on we can make sure it doesn't
happen again
and
that's what you're talking about
um
and
[Music]
you kind of close it out by saying i've
been fighting for 17 years i'm willing
to throw it all away to say back to say
my two to my senior leaders i demand
accountability
and that's it
um pretty simple straightforward message
you hit post
i hit post you hit post um
how long did it take before
you know you started getting texts from
your friends and your senior leadership
good question uh no one's asked me this
question yet so walked in the house
didn't say anything
got upstairs and i was sitting in my
bedroom on the bed my wife was getting
ready for bed
she got a text
she said did you post a video
i was like yep i sure did
she's like you know i won't say that
girl's name she's like so and so my
friend is texting me saying you're going
valve right now i was like oh going what
viral okay
i was like you should probably watch the
video
tell my wife so she watched it and she's
like you need to take this down
we're this is we're gonna get in trouble
take it down
and i was like babe it's already up
but you can't can't put the lid back on
the bottle and even if i could i don't
know if i'd want to
and so this is me saying this in this
moment i was like i really believe in
what i said in that video like i feel
very strongly about it
and so my wife then started feeling the
gravity of what i had just done started
stressing out and so then i went
downstairs was sitting on the couch and
was just kind of thinking and then all
my friends started texting me one of my
friends from marsoc actually texted me
and said stu
everything you said in that video is
correct but it's going to come at way
too high of a personal cost and you're
not going to change anything he's like
take it down
and i told him i was like no this is the
hill i'm willing to die and i'm not
taking it down and then i had one of my
instructors from aitv
who texted me his gunny as a section
leader awesome dude he's like hey sir i
watch your video and i agree with
everything in your video
but
our adversaries could take this video
and use it against us and i think you
need to think about that and i think you
should take it down
and to him i said you know
there's probably even some truth to that
but if we can't fix internally what
we're doing right now
with this conversation that i'm trying
to start then
it's all for nothing
and so i guess those are all three true
stories where i was like you know from
my loved ones from my friends from
people that worked for me
were oh i mean i and there's like 10
other examples right so my phone blew up
that night no one none one in my chain
of command contacted me that night
so just
people that knew me
and
you know i i've never
like my wife and i never like slept in
separate rooms even when we were angry
like early in my marriage i was like i'm
never you're never making me sleep on
the couch right like this is our house
we sleep together we're gonna deal with
stuff
but like that night i slept on the couch
and i bring that up just to illustrate
like that's how stressful it was it was
just like
was she mad just basically because you
were you were torpedoing your own career
yeah like i said i mean we had stability
like in those three years probably for
the first time in our life and she
thought she was going to be there i had
just taken battalion commander scenes so
she knew i was going to be there for at
least another two years and i only had a
year after that until retirement so she
knew she had another three years in
north carolina she had just started a
new job as a teacher the kids were all
in the same school for the first time
she finally had all the stability that
she wanted and then this
took her by complete surprise and she
knew that i probably wouldn't even have
this job much longer so every all the
stability she thought she had you know i
took from her
some people asked me about
this when it was happening and i was
like on social media or something like
that and i got asked about actually no i
think i was getting interviewed on a
news channel
but
you know my response
um
it i guess i drew subconsciously from
what hackworth says when they say oh do
you think you become emotional
and he's like yes
i have become emotional because i've
watched so many good men die
and
um
i am emotional and that's sort of what i
said i said listen
here's a here's a guy that's been
at war for 17 years who i guarantee he's
lost marines and
he's sitting here looking at this
situation saying this is i'm not like
i'm not taking this anymore
when did you hear from your chain of
command the next day
so as a battalion commander i was always
the first one in the office and it just
so happened
that that day my wife had a medical
appointment and i had agreed to drop the
kids off
at like
at school at like let's call it eight
o'clock
and so it was like an abnormal
occurrence
so that's like the one day i didn't show
up early and so
um i take the kids
until now i don't get into work until
like 8 15. and as a battalion commander
you don't tell people when you're coming
in you just
show up at a normal time but i had
texted my option xl like cameron late
and
so i tell you that just to say my co had
stopped by my office and called like
three times
um and my op so called me and was like
hey sir
co was really looking for you should
probably call them and so when i drove
in i got in i think at like 8 30 that
morning
seal
was actually walking because his
building's let's say a two minute walk
from my building he was actually walking
between the buildings and i saw him and
so i stuck my head out the window i was
like do you wanna you want me to come
back to your place he's like no just
meet me in your office
so by the time i went parked my truck
and went into my office like he was
already sitting in my office waiting for
me
and what do you say
the first conversation
between colonel emil and i
i mean he he came off as actually very
caring
keep in mind this is a
career colonel command selected that
doesn't know me very well
i've never met him before my battalion
command so he's had about six weeks of
meetings maybe like
seven meetings with me
so just imagine i mean he's another
professional i'm professional he doesn't
know me right it's not like a guy i've
been working for for a couple years
or even a guy that knows a guy that i
know real well like i don't know anyone
that really knows i mean they're like we
just don't know each other we haven't
developed much of a relationship
so he's like so he posted a video yes
sir and he didn't really there wasn't
much small talk he said i wish you would
have talked to me first if you would
have talked to me first we could have
worked through some of this and that's
and he's right and that's the
appropriate way
and i said yes sir i understand
and he's like i think that this video
might be used
to run messages that may not have been
your intent i wish you would have
thought of that
and again he was right
and then he just stated look there's
going to be an investigation that's
going to take place
and then based on the investigation
we're going to determine what to do
i'd like you to go home take the rest of
the day and i will text you on monday
with where we stand and like all of that
was very reasonable right very
reasonable stuff was this already like
on fox news and uh hitting the news
outlets and all that at this point
no so this was still sort of
you know
your facebook friends you know and then
like or was it how big was it i mean i
think it probably had received
like 10 000 shares
so
i mean by the end of the night it was
picked up by all the major news stations
so in the morning like the commandant's
office knew about it i mean everyone
knew about it but you know it hadn't
been picked up by mainstream media yet
but it does by the end of the day but
like it wasn't like everybody knew
hey when your friend your gunny and your
wife we're all like hey dude
take take it down
yeah what was the question
i mean they
everyone knew
yeah and so my ceo left my xo came in
and i turned over the
battalion to him
and
then i went home
and then
and then when i got home
my co called me an hour later and said
hey i need you to come back in i'm sorry
to jerk you around
oh that was weird i was like all right
you meet me at my office he's like no
meet me in my office
okay
so i meet him in his office and he just
looks at me and says and hands me a
piece of paper and says you've been
relieved for cause based on a lack of
trust and confidence
do you have any questions
yes
what do i do now he's like i need you to
come in tomorrow
he's like what will probably happen is
there will be an investigation and i
don't think they're going to keep you
here he's like they'll probably move you
up to quantico
and
general alford asked to maintain the
investigation so that he can take care
of you that's what he said i was like
okay
i'm like trying to trying to like
reconcile that in my mind
and but at the end of the day like i
kind of knew i'd be relieved over it and
i just said okay sir and so i signed the
piece of paper that's that i'd been
relieved
i walked out
and i actually made a post like
immediately after it's still up on my
pages my facebook and linkedin and just
and i was very appreciative i said
i think effective of 1400 today i've
been relieved and my command is doing
exactly what i would have done i'd like
to thank them for the opportunity of
getting to serve as the aitb battalion
commander and i look forward to the next
chapter right so very
appreciative post
obviously something changed for your
regimental commander or somebody talked
to him and said all right this is what
we're doing yeah uh and by just so
everyone just so civilians know what
you're talking about relieved of command
means you just got fired yeah so you got
fired and battalion command is a huge
stepping stone and it's a huge
responsibility so the ramifications were
i would never get promoted again
and
you know as you worked through it in
your mind i had been relieved so i'd
been fired so i knew i would never be
promoted again but i knew that there was
still potential for legal action
right so like best case i
am just like a disgraced lieutenant
colonel cubicle somewhere olympian
towards retirement
but you know worst case was i could be
separated out via legal action
and so i didn't know i was just unknown
at that time
how many days was it until you posted
your next video
so that occurred on a friday
and
then
i went into i said
i haven't gotten into all this in the
story so this is new stuff
i went home
and you know my wife
now had kind of wrapped her head around
life was changing and she was still down
for the cause at that point
so she was thinking like maybe we'd go
down to florida my parents had vacation
rentals and like manage the vacation
rentals
and i had had i tried to do like a
father-son days with my kids and i
already had a pre-planned one with my
oldest kid down on the outer banks she
was like do you want to cancel the thing
with paul my oldest son and i was like
no i think i could probably use like a
day away with just one of my kids
she's like we need to talk to the boys
and i was like all right i was like i
don't know if i can do it tonight i've
just been fired why don't we
you know give me the night
and so went to bed i was the last night
i actually slept with my wife that night
slept with my something the same bed
with my wife
got up the next morning got the three
boys on the couch and i told them
hey guys your dad was fired
but i was fired for doing something that
i thought was right
i wasn't fired for doing something
you know bad or nefarious i want you
guys to hear it from me because your
your friends at school are probably
going to tell you
and
nothing
is going to change for you you're going
to get to keep living here and i may
have to go to quantico to work for the
next three years but you'll get to
remain in school
that's what i believed at the time so i
told him that
then i
took my oldest son and
while we were out spending the day on
the boat
all i was thinking about was what do i
do
and
i do i kind of skipped over this to go
back
when i made that post that just thanked
my command
when i was on my social media i read a
public comment from one of my previous
bosses so when i was at soi as a captain
the lieutenant colonel was my battalion
commander that he did a lot for me
he retired as an o6 he had gotten on my
social media and said if stuart schiller
was honorable he would resign
and he didn't state that he was my
previous boss
or that he was like a mentor to me
didn't email me didn't text me and i
felt like
i mean that really was like a stab in
the back to me
because a lot of general officers that
are on linkedin they prefer linkedin not
facebook so that's why i had a lot
linkedin too
a lot of the senior officers knew who he
was and so for him to call me out like
that
and so i'm struggling with when i'm with
my kid on the boat i'm struggling with
they relieved me without even an
investigation like i knew my job was at
risk when i posted that video
but like i feel like a tolerant
organization would have been like hey
we're going to let investigation play
out we're going to let you sit and calm
down obviously this was personal but
you've broken some rules and let's let
the investigation play out and we'll see
where the chips fall like that's the
reasonable but they they obviously
fired me within like 12 hours were you
surprised when you got released
i was surprised i didn't let an
investigation take place i really was it
did not i didn't expect that like when i
was calculating what would happen i
thought i might be benched while an
investigation took place but i didn't
think i'd be relieved immediately
but
even that probably wasn't enough to push
me it was that next comment from my old
boss where then i like while i was
sitting there with my son playing at the
seeds of i don't know if this
organization cares about me as much as i
care about it
and so i just was struggling with this
and so then it came back to like what do
i want to do like if none of them care
about me
do i want to limp towards retirement for
the next three years because that's best
case
and i just came to the decision like
no i can't live my life like that like
this was never supposed to be a career
this was always supposed to be something
that was fulfilling i don't care about
the money as much as other people might
i really don't like i'll be fine
and i thought i need to get ahead of
this and i'm not going to let them just
dictate the terms i'm going to resign
and i'm going to tell them that because
i still believe in what i said and they
haven't addressed any of that
and so after i spent the whole day with
my kid on saturday
i kind of came to that conclusion
saturday night and so then on we slept
in
out there on the beach we had a hotel
and then on sunday morning i took him
back
you know to the house and i dropped him
off with my wife and i was you know had
been fired on friday so i said hey can i
go out to the farm i went out there
every once in a while just kind of like
me time and she was like absolutely i
get it and i went out there so on my 50
acres i've got two abandoned school
buses that i put out there it's kind of
like trailers and we actually i i listen
to a non-profit called a hero and we do
suicide prevention for
like outdoor treatment for veterans and
so that's why i have it i've had it i've
had retreats out there for the veterans
but when i went out there that sunday i
essentially on one of the school buses
set up a video and the message of the
second video was
you fired me i don't think you care
about me i'm resigning effectively
immediately i don't want any money i
don't want any benefits
and
then i and i posted it and that's where
you know it really quickly became an
escalating series of events between the
marine corps and myself
yeah and
you know all this
even your original message you were
talking about what you wanted was
accountability i mean obviously i wrote
a book called extreme ownership and this
is the the very
that's what it is right and that's what
you're that's what you're saying even
after this video comes out
there's still no one responding to
anything in the video and and they also
did some things where
they're
like they put they put some
uh
they made some pr maneuvers on you on
you
saying hey we're gonna make sure that he
gets the help that he needs something
along those lines yeah so after the
second video came out
now so again this was sunday i was fired
on friday so i haven't been to work yet
so it's sunday night
well after i make a second video i mean
it's 45 minute drive i post it from my
farm it's a 45 minute drive back to my
house
by the time i got back my wife had
already seen it
and was very upset and you hadn't
pre-briefed your wife on no any of this
no that's why she was justifiably very
angry
and you know i won't go into all the
details of that but
that's where the
that's where the path started to diverge
between my wife and i
and
so i ended up going and staying in a
motel so i was in a day's end for the
rest of the week and
my yes the question you asked was they
started making statements
the marine corps
pao office public affairs office
released a statement that was all over
the media because now these videos were
getting picked up that second video that
i did was the banner of fox news like if
you went to foxnews.com that day like
that was the first thing was my
my face on a school bus right
and so the marine corps was trying to
get out in front of it and they released
a statement that said we are trying to
locate lieutenant colonel sheller to
protect himself
to protect him against himself and his
family and i was like what
and i had my phone on me the entire time
and i had even talked to my battalion xo
for like 20 minutes like i was texting
my friends and i was like
if the marine corps was really trying to
find me like they didn't think to text
me they didn't think to call me and so
like potentially potentially the public
affairs office arm
just wasn't talking to like whoever
should have been calling me and just got
out ahead of it first
but like the other part of it is maybe
like they really just didn't care about
me at all and they just put that out but
like again i'm having all these
indicators of this like this escalating
thing of like me feeling like what i
said is right all right you should show
some sympathy and they're like no i'm
going to poke you in the chest because
what you did was broke the rules and
then i'm like well no come back and
listen to what i'm saying like no you're
still breaking the rules i'm gonna make
it worse for you and so like each one of
these is just an example of i'm like if
they cared about me they would have
called
[Music]
um
one thing that i noticed and i heard you
talking about it you know at the end of
that second video
you're getting emotional
and you're like um
asking for accountability and then kind
of ranting against everything a little
bit
um and you say you know follow me and
we'll bring the whole [ __ ] system
down so you're
you know going hard
and i heard you i heard you later say
like yeah i didn't choose the best words
yeah i appreciate asking that so people
have asked me a lot
do you regret it because
my life has dramatically changed lost a
lot gained a lot
the one the
thing i've come through this with the
understanding is i wouldn't change my
original position or the events
at all like i don't apologize but there
are
certain
ways that i delivered the message that i
would absolutely go back and tweak and
the one shining example is the we're
going to bring the whole [ __ ] system
down in that second video and even in
the third video i say a couple of things
that like could it or were stripped out
of context
and so
yeah you gotta understand
i mean in that second video like that
emotion wasn't fake like i knew
i was giving up everything like i i
i was terrified
and i was emotional and i didn't take
multiple takes that was like one take
jay-z get on the mic drop it post it
right like there was no editing of that
video
and so
i wish i could go back because it
allowed the media to just paint me as
this violent extremist
and i don't think i ever came anywhere
close to that like obviously in my i
can't say obviously in my head i was
trying to communicate that the system
has centralized power it was corrupt and
it needs to be fundamentally changed but
in the emotional
outpouring of the moment i said i want
to bring the whole [ __ ] system down
you know like i was just mad
um but and i went back and clarified
like in my like three days later in a
post i put in a constitutional matter
with one loud voice but like no one
reads the follow-up you know what i mean
you get that one shot that's right
especially when it comes to like viral
type videos that are going to get out
there no one's fault no one's following
up with that
um
you get home from that video and your
wife is like you didn't pre-brief your
wife now your wife is just like
well
no this isn't this isn't going to happen
that's right
yeah i mean and so
yeah i'm probably not going to develop
much more of the story with my wife and
i but i will say you know i still like
this past christmas after all this was
done you know i got out on christmas eve
we spent as a family all of christmas
together we went to a water park
together like i still very much love her
we are still going through a divorce
this situation was very challenging and
there's things that we both would have
done differently
and there's
reasons the reasons i didn't say
anything is because i knew what she
would say and again this was very
important to me
but i think more than anything the
reason we're going through a divorce and
we didn't decide to reconcile is because
what this situation did was illustrate
the trajectory of my life
and how i'm always going to be on the
move
and i think in one comment she
summarized it with i just in retirement
want to learn how to play golf and you
want to fundamentally change the
government right those are two very
different things and the story that i
just painted you for the last 17 years i
mean this woman has stuck by me and
suffered through a lot and like she
deserves a little bit of stability she
hasn't had it her her whole adult life
and
she justifiably deserves that um
and you know she's still the mother of
my children so i'll never have anything
bad to say about it there's talking
about the verbiage that i would have
changed there's absolutely things i
would have changed with how i handled my
situation with her
you know there's you know things that i
still look back on and it makes me sad
but
at the end of the day you can't look
back you just got to look forward i i've
tried to do the right thing i obviously
hit some minds while moving forward but
i kept moving forward
and you know she's still a big part of
my life and so that is what it is you
know
i was a rebellious kid
and i like was a rebellious kid i
listened to hardcore music i didn't
listen to my parents i didn't like
school i didn't do good in school i
didn't i was like a rebellious kid you
can just trace that streak all the way
back to my birth
so
when i look at your
your from you what we talked about today
from your birth on up it's like i don't
see that streak
and then all of a sudden it just kind of
manifests itself i get
look you're talking about when you're in
ramadi you're giving away money to these
locals and you're thinking this doesn't
seem like the i'm thinking that too
doing the same thing i'm in ramadi in
2006. we're forming relationships with
people i'm thinking okay well
i guess this will move us in one
direction but i'm not sitting there as a
obedient you know uh slave as to what
i'm being told this is what you're being
told to do do it i always pushed back on
my leadership throughout my career
always had that rebellious streak
and this just kind of like do do you
when you look back at your life
do you notice things along the way that
are indicators that you had sort of a
limit to what you would take i mean
what's movie movie reference what's the
movie reference where the guy is like an
accountant or something and then he just
kind of loses it falling down yeah
am i right because i never even saw that
movie but i remember it yeah michael
does that's what happens right he's a
normal guy yeah something happens
he's not gonna take it anymore yeah
nothing really happened he just reached
this point in general
at the beginning like there wasn't like
any indicators
that was the beginning of the movie no
not really yeah everything life like
traffic so what do you think stu are you
do you see indicators in the past where
you're you're thinking like man i always
had this idiot
no michael douglas basically going to
suicidal rampage i don't think the
comparison is fair again
i think
yes to your point i didn't always push
back i mean i started to give some
examples there
with my regimental commander to kind of
paint a picture of
you know at a certain point i started to
just solidify who i was what my values
were and it's funny
a lot of people have asked me this which
i'm sort of surprised by the question
i've actually been surprised by a lot of
the questions people give me but one of
the questions was why now
you've been in you're in ramadi in 07
you did all this your whole life why now
and they were asking that question
almost implying as if there's a democrat
and that's a president and like i used
my platform to exploit now
to become
popular the truth is
i think
people grow
develop an appreciation right as a young
first lieutenant i wanted to go serve my
country
you know when i look back on
george bush's philosophy to export
democracy that was obviously stupid but
if you asked 23 year old stuart schiller
or you know i'm watching the marines in
fallujah all i could see were the
marines running through fallujah i used
to love the movie black hawk down when
you watch that movie it's like it
glorifies it if you look at the
operational failures in somalia that led
to that event but like i didn't have a
deeper appreciation for that so
i mean the question you're asking me is
like why did i get to that moment i had
just at that point had enough education
and experiences and i was in
enough of a position of authority that
there just wasn't many other people like
me at that moment in time willing to say
what needed to be said
so as time goes on after this when do
they actually like arrest you do you get
arrested right yeah
yeah so i posted that second video
like a week goes by
now you did a september 11th video too
right yep we did a third video you're
still not arrested yet nope then i even
did a fourth video in my charlie's
where um i basically
after my my second or third video was
like
just kind of an outpouring of emotion
where my second video was very angry i
resigned my third video i was really
just talking about violence and i was
trying to like
take the sharp edge off the second video
but i still don't really go back to
accountability but after my third video
now all my friends are texting me and
being like dude
you're looking a little crazy you look a
little erratic great
and so
and
keep in mind like after my second video
even though the pao office put that
message out that they were trying to
find me then when i went into work they
command directed a mental health
evaluation so my mental health was being
attacked from all these different angles
and it's so hard to defend mental health
because if you really are crazy anything
you say is marginalized because you're
crazy right so it's like you're crazy
and i'm like no i'm not well that's what
a crazy person would say you know that's
that's catch 22 right that's the book
catch 22. if you're crazy you don't
think you're crazy that's right so how
do you defend it so anyway so did you
start wondering no
you know what you're laughing but like
when everyone tells you it you do start
to question like you know if everyone in
this room is crazy like what does that
make me
either i'm the only sane one or maybe i
am the crazy one
so
after the third video they actually
offered me a deal a legal deal
i could have just taken it now i've been
that but i was like
man there's a lot of talk of me being
crazy and i didn't help myself with
these two videos
i was like i need to end and bring the
message back
and so that's when i made that fourth
video in my charlie's like general
mckenzie is like i can't think in
military history where someone is so
obviously culpable
like it's just clear like the emperor
has no clothes you have to see it and i
could go through all the details as to
why i think that but that was the fourth
video i was trying to bring the message
back to accountability and so after the
fourth video is when they gave me a gag
order
and just said i mean the gag word was
crazy i don't think i've actually
released the verbage of it but it was
like
if you talk to him and he talks to him
and they say that you said that you're
going to jail like anything like online
chat rooms like any email if you
communicate
this was because they offered you a deal
but then you made another video that's
right
and so now they didn't know what to do
now now i'm moving faster than their
legal deals are moving faster than the
investigation and they haven't actually
charged me with anything so they're
they're starting to get scared
because i don't know if scared the right
word but they they don't know how to
handle it they don't know how to address
it there's a guy that's not taking the
deals and he's still making statements
and they and everything they've done at
this point hasn't been effective in
stopping it
so they hit you with the is this when
they arrest you no this is after the
fourth video is when they gave me a gag
order so i'm still not in jail
you so now you're not allowed to talk to
anybody that's right you're not allowed
to post on social media that's right not
to communicate in any form
you're just on lockdown
yeah a couple points
number one
i'm i constantly say to clients and
people and friends
we don't make good decisions when we're
emotional like don't try
this started as a joke when i was a
young enlisted guy like we would go out
drinking and make decisions you know and
the joke was hey don't make decisions
don't make life-changing decisions i
would volunteer for platoons and do
stuff like that
so this is a good example right
you take a step back
and and say okay
where am i going to be
strategically and this is another thing
i talk about all the time is
taking a step back and saying okay how
where does it how does this play out
strategic from a strategic perspective
where am i going to end up just just
things to think about which you're
clearly like hey here's some wording i
could have changed here's a
thing that would have helped out my
relationship with so there's always
things that if you can try and take a
step back they're going to be beneficial
to you almost guaranteed
the risk to that is time the risk to
that is time also the risk to that is
you can rationalize
to not do anything that's right you can
rationalize to get to a point where you
say you know what it's not worth it yep
and
and again is it smart to do that
calculus it probably is because my my
feeling i don't i don't know you but my
feeling is if you were to run the
calculus
you would have still came to the same
conclusion you might have executed your
plan a little bit differently
but it's important too if you can take a
step back run the calculus so that way
the course that you plot will be the
most effective course in what you're
trying to do and this is just general
you know i've got some friends and they
know who they are who call me from time
to time
super emotional and i gotta talk them
through like what the strategic
perspective is what it looks like over
the long term
and and how to make the next step
forward so good good lesson learned
and
again from my from just talking to you
today i think you still would have made
the same you would come to the same
conclusion that this is something that
i don't want to use the word passionate
not that you see just that you were
passionate about it but
you were
you were convicted you had conviction
about what you were saying
um and you know
something else from my perspective in a
in an ownership and an accountability
perspective
that i think people don't understand as
leaders
is
if you make a mistake
and you take ownership of the mistake
that you've made
then what you can do is you can fix the
mistake
and you can actually change things and
just because you say hey this was my
fault doesn't mean you necessarily
get fired or have to
resign
you know
any of these senior leaders could say
hey this is what we thought
we're not perfect i'm not perfect i made
a mistake i you know i did that i did
that with i made a a speech coming from
president biden if i was in president
biden's shoes what i would have said and
it was like hey i made this mistake we
under we underestimated that means i
underestimated that means i thought that
the afghan forces were stronger that
means i thought that the taliban was
weaker i miss
misassessed and miscalculated how this
unfolded here's what we're doing to fix
it
and and this is the thing that i think a
lot of leaders don't understand when a
person does that when a leader does that
the the team
doesn't think oh you see that's right
you were messed up no they think oh okay
yep he messed up but he's humble enough
to take ownership and we're going to get
it fixed and we and we'll support him
now this is my whole freaking career was
taking ownership when things went wrong
and and so i i think just again to some
of these senior leaders
when you take ownership of something
it's not
it's a step forward it's not a step
backward it is a true step forward and
by the way when you blame other people
or you deny or you act like it didn't
happen that is a step backward that's
what people don't understand that's what
leaders don't understand they don't
understand that saying what wasn't it
was the afghan people's fault it was the
afghan military's fault that's not a
step forward
it feels like one
but it's not it's a step backward
because every single other person knows
people know the truth about what's going
on they can sense it and i think that's
one of the reasons why your videos were
widely shared because people thought
this guy he knows what he's he believes
what he's saying and he
he's speaking from a perspective of
truth like people people saw that yeah
people weren't like oh he's trying to
blame the leadership what's wrong with
that guy no people like yeah he's trying
to blame the leadership because the
leadership is wrong
and they should admit that and they
should take ownership of it
[Applause]
so you get gagged
gag order comes then what do you at what
point you get arrested right so
i got gagged on let's call a friday i
went through a saturday sunday
monday tuesday wednesday thursday friday
so now it's going into the next weekend
and
that following week on the tuesday
wednesday i knew that
the secretary of defense the chairman of
the joint chiefs
and general mckenzie were going to be
testifying to the house and the senate
and so
i calculated
if i violated the gag order they might
have a disproportional response and that
that would bring attention to the whole
message that i was trying to illustrate
so i made another post that was
this one was probably my most insightful
you know it was it had some like
insightful language in terms of not like
revolutionary insightful but i mean like
personal attacks on people like i
attacked all the like the last four
presidents you know i attacked general
officers and i didn't say anything that
was untrue but like i said some like
hard stuff to hear it wasn't very it
wasn't like a uniting message it was
just like a
[ __ ] you to everyone
and
again i even put in the post i'm ready
to go to jail but before i made the post
i read
the entire ucmj manual for quartz
marshall and so i knew what the
requirements were to send me to jail and
quite honestly i didn't think that they
had the criteria to send me to jail i
was kind of prepared to go to jail but i
didn't think that they had the legal
ability to do so
for violating a gag order that i thought
was illegal
and so
that was the only time i violated the
gag order was that one time
and then i showed up at zero eight on
monday
and they had pmo waiting for me and they
sent me to jail and the way they did it
was they wrote on the document that i
was a flight risk which was like just an
outward line i showed up at zero eight
on monday right i've been to work every
day
on time the full time answering every
phone call so like it's just a lie and
no one will be held accountable for that
but that was what it was and uh got to
jail that monday morning and but my
calculation was correct
all the generals had to answer questions
to include the secretary of defense
about why i was in jail because i went
to jail on that monday and they started
their testimony on tuesday and wednesday
and then i was out you know six days out
i was a total nine days
so you end up getting charged with
article 88 contempt toward
officials article 89 disrespect towards
superior commissioned officers article
90
willfully disobeying
superior commissioned officers article
92 dereliction in the performance of
duties article 92 failure to obey order
or regulation article 133
conduct on becoming an officer and a
gentleman
how long did it take for that trial
process to come about
usually it takes
like months
they did mine five days
after i got out of jail
so you spent six days nine days in jail
nine days in jail and what were you
doing in jail just sitting there
yeah
i was in a solitary cell yeah
i honestly all i did was write so the
first two days i didn't have
any any writing gear or books and then
by like day three my lawyer was able to
drop off like all these legal pads pens
books and he gave me my command
investigation that just had
i mean we can get that if we want but i
mean all these statements from these
other officers that just like weren't
just
lies straight up personal attacks and so
i was like writing on the league just
example of like oh he showed up late to
work that kind of thing oh yeah so
he was smiling in his command photo
we don't smile in command photos i knew
i didn't like him when he when i saw
that
[Laughter]
another one another one this one guy
they use that in the court of law
against you
these aren't like i don't like people
that smile either i agree with that guy
these aren't just like you know side of
the mouth comments these are on
statements that they sign right i mean
these are formal statements this one guy
i was at the beach with his family a
week previous and i went to his house
for dinner two weeks previous with our
families to hang out and like when i was
in that motel where like you know i had
miller like can scattered my life's
falling apart like i probably really
could have used a friend and he was
texting me like hey stu how you doing
man just want to make sure you're all
right is there anything we can talk
about like why are you doing this
he then screenshotted those
and brought them to the investigating
officer unsolicited to say look i was
trying to figure out what his motives
are like this stu sheller is just a
[ __ ] nefarious character have never
been about tie and commander and i'm
like
who
does that like what
man
does that
blood in the water oh there's blood in
the water man sharks are gonna pounce
yeah but they didn't realize that i
wasn't you know
yeah
so you end up going to trial and this
trial the judge you said looked at your
record and was like hey well
where'd this come from the judge
i don't think wanted me to plead guilty
so it wasn't you know all those charges
you read off and there was like all
these findings of facts the only choice
there was only one choice
except guilty for all of them at special
court martial or pleaded not guilty to
all of them in general like so to get in
the weeds about what any of them said it
was almost irrelevant
and so so if you did not not guilty what
would have happened i would have gone to
general court martial and i'd remained
in jail for another four or five months
while they prepare on pre-trial while
they prepared the general court-martial
procedure and then i would have gone and
tried to plead not guilty to all of them
in general
check and then you you
pled guilty to all of them again
there's no like i want to plead guilty
to these two and not these three is it
there's no point in looking at the
details of them it was do you plead
guilty to all of this you don't even
need to read it stu do you plead guilty
to all of this at special misdemeanor
you get a the lowest character
characterization of discharge is general
under honorable which they'll determine
later or
you go to general plead not guilty and
if you get found guilty of one of any of
these it's a felony and you'll get
dishonorable and you'll sit in here for
another four months
and i'll tell you what even with that
choice i thought very strongly about
doing the general because i was going to
say bro you're at this point
i know god
i'm kind of surprised i know i almost
did that and i think and to the judges
you know sentiment i really think i
could have won but you got what i asked
myself was what's the most important
thing
the most important thing the reason i
gave all of this up was not to beat them
it was to preserve the message of
accountability
and if i felt deep inside that i had
broken some of the rules for me to beat
them based on undue command influence
and legal leupold i felt like would have
marginalized my message of
accountability and for me to plead
guilty for breaking the rules and then
look at them and say look i'm not
apologizing but i'm accepting
accountability i felt it strengthened my
message and it also expedited my exit so
that i could come on you know jocko's
podcast and talk about how general
mckenzie needs to be fired right so for
all those reasons uh again i it made
more sense to plead guilty
and that so that was kind of almost
anticlimactic
a little bit you you i'll tell you
though there was some drama and so like
i said the fastest court martial from
exit of uh jail and agreement in the
history of the marine corps
also one of those charges like 88 i
think i was the first officer charged
since vietnam like they were just like
throwing stuff on the wall right
but they released the command
investigation with all those like it's
just crazy things that those officers
said to the media with my medical
investigation so that
selective articles could be written
about like how i was a violent extremist
and it was just blatantly false stuff
like i'm still on the fence of whether i
should sue for libel or just like move
forward
but so once they leaked that
investigation to your point the judge
the judge was like if that's true like
this is criminal like those people
should be brought to the court not
lieutenant colonel sheller and so the
marine corps was like forced to do
another command investigation on the
elite command investigation so they did
another command investigation and so
then i asked for that other command
investigation because it had to do with
me and they're like no you got to go
through freedom of information act i was
like let me give this straight
so you had an investigation that was
about me that you leaked through the
improper channels you were scolded by
the judge you created a new
investigation still about me about your
improper handling and the only way for
me to get that is to go through the
problem
problem
the proper freedom of information act
like that's correct and i was like ah
you know this is like
have you done that have you requested it
i haven't ever come home you got a
request i don't know it's probably
already burned to the ground i'll be
honestly but i probably will so going
back i probably will sue for libel this
one publication and i'll probably
freedom of information act to add to
that libel suit but
like right now the most important thing
again
is the message
and making sure that people understand i
mean there's fundamental breakdowns that
are not being addressed apolitically
that's what i want to change so like do
i have grievances that i can legally
pursue sure but that's like i said
earlier like money's really not that
important to me
so
we'll figure it out and so you
part of your re part of the deal was you
you resigned and you were done you're
done in the marine corps that's right at
17 years maybe 18 years now 17 17 years
yeah
and then
you got out what just before christmas
christmas eve christmas eve that's right
that was it that was it
where were you when you were out
what was that night like
uh my family came down actually yeah so
hung out with my family just acted like
it wasn't happening
i honestly don't think it's hit me
because right now you know someone
that's listening to the show we're
taping this in early january but after
christmas with my family then i've
started doing all these media shows
because i've been on a gag order for the
last four months so i don't think the
reality has actually hit me yet
it's gonna come when i'm
done doing all this media and i'm
sitting in my place by myself with
nothing to do
that's probably when it's gonna be like
oh [ __ ] but i've i've stayed too busy
for it to be real yet
so what's so here you are here i am i
mean this is only freaking
three weeks right that's right what's
next what are you doing
so
i just wanna what's the new mission the
so i wanna illustrate like why i'm so
upset with general mackenzie
and so i'm gonna just take a second talk
about that and then then i'll answer
your question through that so the reason
i in that fourth video try to prefer
charges against general mckenzie which
is my legal right to do explain
i didn't touch on that explain what you
did you explain what you did there
in the manual for court martials rule
137 clearly states that any member of
the ucmj can prefer charges against
another member in the ucmj
now that when you prefer that means that
charge sheet has to be routed up to the
first general officer with general court
martial authority sometimes it's at the
colonel level
and so the strategy there was
i knew general alford was trying to hold
me accountable i knew he would never
have the courage to refer
charges from my preferral but then he
would have to publicly declare that he
wasn't going to seek accountability
against the general and he was seeking
accountability against me so i was using
that tactic to illustrate the hypocrisy
of the system but they denied me the
ability to even route it which is my
legal right to do i mean it was just i
mean illegal in my opinion it doesn't
matter so they don't allow me to do that
the reason i was trying to prefer those
charges is because
general mckenzie is the centcom
combatant commander he works directly
for the secretary of defense who works
directly for the president what happened
was in you know the the story you gave
in the withdrawal from afghanistan
general mckenzie and i know the
operational planners that developed the
plans for the withdrawal they submitted
the national security council four or
five plans most of them included keeping
bhaka mayor base but they needed 2 500
troops if you go and watch general
mckenzie's testimony on the back side he
says i tried to say that we needed 2500
troops why that's relevant is because
they determined that that number was
what was capable of maintaining bagram
air base when president biden and the
national security council said no you
got to go below 2500
then general mckenzie was at a critical
moment right so as a as the senior
military advisor you have a
responsibility to convince your boss why
you should execute your plan now you
can't force your boss to do that but
every staff officer knows how to get i
mean as an operations officer there's an
art to making sure that my boss does the
plan that i think is best because i know
better than he does in a lot of ways so
it's artful but he failed to do that so
once he failed to do that then he looked
at the restraints that were imposed upon
his plan if he didn't feel like he could
execute the plan effectively without
undue loss of life he had a moral
obligation to resign he did not do that
once he didn't resign at that point
he is accountable he doesn't get to go
back after the fact and say no i told
the president of the national security
council 2500 and they didn't listen to
me it doesn't matter that you didn't
convince him and you didn't resign it
you're the senior military advisor so
for all those reasons i think general
mckenzie should be held accountable
right now just as i've started this
media tour
72 hours ago the white house released
the general mackenzie was being replaced
in the spring by a nuisant comp
combatant commander
um and i don't think it's a coincidence
to be completely honest with you because
i've been hitting the media pretty hard
that guy he's going to undermine his
whole career if he doesn't raise his
hand and say he should be accountable
before he exits so that's one thing i
think the operational level of war which
is at the combatant commander level
linked to the political policy strategic
level of war which is the national
security council executive branch is
where we're failing wars where we failed
vietnam it's where we failed the gui
generation and how you do that as you
hold leaders accountable at that level
and right now congress and the executive
branch aren't holding up their end of
the bargain i'll give an example of what
i think is wrong with congress
when i went to
i placed myself in jail in a lot of ways
to illustrate something and i
underestimated
i guess i overestimated congress's
ability to do anything because
bipartisan took turns with their sound
bites of anger about the failed
afghanistan withdrawal and then guess
what
nothing
congress's given by the founding fathers
leverage over the dod is the budget
and what was not in the news is six days
previous they unanimously approved a 740
billion dollar 22 fiscal year budget and
not one of those vocally outraged
congressional representatives said hey
you're asking for 740 billion dollars
who's accountable from the afghanistan
trial show me metrics of effectiveness
for the 21 budget because to do that
would require courage to do that would
get spun as potentially anti-military
and that would go against
self-preservation
so
what do i want going forward i want the
operational level of war combatant
commanders to start being held
accountable in the same manner that they
were in world war ii i mean look at how
many generals lincoln fired before he
got to grant and grant wasn't a good
tactician but he had operational
foresight he knew how to stick with it
the second thing i think is we need
leaders not politicians so i've got a
website
authenticamericans.com where you can see
some of my political views but
ultimately it's where you can support me
and i've also got a second website
votesforvets.org
because i think we need leaders not
politicians i've in the four months that
i've been on a gag order gone out and
organized a bunch of people running in
the 22 race so i've got five senators
and 20 congressional representatives
that all i think embody the leadership
and courage that we need in politics and
some of them i think have a real good
shot at winning some of them are more of
a long shot
but it's i have the ability right now
with the platform i've built to raise
money bring in media to some of these
races
bring in different organizations to
support some of these leaders that i
think need to be up in uh
in d.c and is that also linked through
authenticamericans.com for the for the
people that are running for the vets
that are running votes for vets okay
number four so votesforvets.org is
really where you can see most of those
candidates
um my website authentic americans really
you can donate to the disabled veterans
pack through authentic americans and
that money ultimately will go to support
the coalition that i built
but i they're they're separate authentic
americans is really my brand and my
thinking and i don't i'm not gonna run
most likely in the 22 race i plan to
just support these other veterans i've
been through a lot like i said i think i
need to stabilize a little bit
and reassess the landscape before just
continuing to sprint
but i do think you know my whole life
has been america i love america and i
love foreign diplomacy and i think the
federal politics game is where you
really make that those changes and so i
see myself running for something but it
probably won't be until 24-ish
so that's what you're going to do you're
planning to go into politics right now
in in the future in the future i mean
right now i'm probably going to write a
book
i'm probably going to you know figure
out where my house is going to be at
so you know i'm going to spend the next
couple of years getting my foundation
stable
until i see something that i think makes
sense
it's a lot going on man there's a lot
going on man i can't believe you only
got out a month ago that's right that's
kind of crazy i it seemed like longer
time had
[Laughter]
passed uh
you're on social media
um
you're on facebook on instagram on
twitter yeah if you go to my website all
my social media is linked at the bottom
so if you just go to
authenticamericans.com you can find all
my pages it's all at stuart sheller
s-c-h-e-l-l-e-r
um
yeah it seems like we're at a decent
place to close it out it's been over
three hours uh
echo charles yes sir any questions
i don't actually i was going to say dude
why don't you like write a book or
something i guess
you are gonna so there you go yeah i've
been writing all these social media
posts and this one guy commented me the
other day like he was i think he was
trying to be nice he's like hey stu have
you ever thought about writing a book
instead of slowly writing a book over
facebook yeah
facebook seems to be like your primary
well the reason social media i mean
instagram and like tick tock or really
the new generation but facebook allows
long written posts and so really now
that if you look at it linkedin has
has a smaller character limit and so
what i've done now is it's the same post
on facebook and linkedin so really the
linkedin
character limit is like the exact
character limit of all my posts because
i usually write like two pages and then
i try to pare them down for the
character limit um but it just goes to i
think the attention span of our current
generation like it has to be in
digestible chunks you get one of your
books and it's a lot harder to get them
digest but if you hit them with like
five posts separated by three days you
gotta i think a much higher chance of
getting them to digest some of that what
are you hearing from the marine corps
right now
they've gone calm silent right they have
a lot of articles have been written on
me since i got out and started doing
this media and the same statement is
we're not going to comment on a civilian
that used to serve in the marine corps
right so they've got like one comment
that's we're not going to comment about
it and so we'll see though i'm hitting
them with a lot of media so that might
change but like you said it's only been
like one week since post christmas
they've been back so who knows
what do you what about your friends in
the marine corps what are they saying
nothing i mean the the
lieutenant colonels that were closest to
me in the investigation that i've made
i've gone a couple interviews and just
illustrated what they said they've
obviously gone calm silent all these
other guys that i know have come online
i've been like that's [ __ ] that they
did that
and so i think they're probably having a
hard time kind of reconciling what they
did at least i would if i were them i
mean i can't speak for them but i can
say i've had a lot of guys speak up and
say i can't believe they did that like
that's so snake in the grass-ish
yeah i mean um
you said you've listened to this podcast
a little bit i i am a huge fan of the
marine corps
in fact my my family says that whenever
i talk about the marine corps i have a
quote
and they'll joke about it i say the
marine corps is freaking squared away
that's what i tell if for whatever
reason i'm with my family and the marine
corps comes up i'll be like marine corps
freaking squared away and it's the truth
i i love the marine corps i worked
alongside the marine corps
pretty much my whole career and just i
think the marine corps is outstanding
and
this is uh this is rough
it's rough to watch this unfold well to
be clear i love the marine corps and i
think the marine corps is pretty squared
away but that comes from
you know the individual is such a high
caliber
person holistically in the marine corps
the problem is the centralization of
power over time and it kind of puts the
blinders on so there's some fundamental
things that need to be addressed but
everything that i'm doing is not from
contempt or
or hate it's from a place of love i have
i hold high regard for the marines and i
still think highly of them
i'll uh tell you what you do you take
that that 65 page draft that you had
they got rejected yeah and then what you
what you cut it down to 30 yeah so that
other 35 pages
that's what you put in your book yeah
there you go because we all kind of want
to hear about that yeah yeah
right on stu you got any closing
thoughts before we uh shut it down
now i'll just echo to your audience as i
watched my saga unfold in the media
the mainstream media is so polarized
right now it was very hard to get a true
assessment of like how people even felt
watching the news because it almost felt
like people were taking my statements
and trying to fit them into whatever
their narrative was and shows like yours
podcasts like yours youtube channels i
was actually getting much more accurate
feedback from what people thought than
mainstream media so i really believe
going forward if the mainstream media
can't figure out how to reconcile kind
of their own polarized views that
platforms like yours are even more
important so i just encourage you to
continue the good work brother
well it will and there was recently uh
some information that came out about
joe rogan and he's just annihilating the
mainstream media which is awesome it's
just
total destruction i mean maybe
two three four times what the mainstream
media has for listeners rogan has so
and and he's one of you know he's the
leader he's the the head of the pack but
there's a lot of other another a lot of
other
uh people out there that are doing the
same thing trying to get the word out
and trying to talk
in a nuanced way about things and
you know
you're a perfect example of a guy that's
going to get interviewed and have
they're going to interview with
questions for sound bites that they can
make headlines that the people will
click that's their goal and so
you know having you on here to actually
give your perspective
your full perspective say whatever you
want like that's the goal so people can
actually hear and understand where
you're coming from and i think that's
important
yeah
well uh thanks for coming on man i
appreciate it thanks for traveling all
the way out here i know you uh never
made it to camp pendleton or 29 palms
for it to be stationed but you finally
got to visit san diego at least for a
little bit
thanks for sharing your story
thanks for sharing your concerns thanks
for sharing your lessons learned
um
and i know what you did and what you're
doing is not the easiest path
but you're standing by what you believe
to be right and what i believe to be
right
which is people need to take ownership
when things happen
and that is commendable
and i hope uh that despite the negative
impacts that this has had on you on your
life i hope it eventually has a positive
impact
for the marine corps for the military at
large and of course
for america and on top of all that ma'am
thanks for your service absolutely yeah
hey uh a year down the road bring me
back on the show we'll see where i'm at
awesome man thank you all right
and with that
stuart sheller has left the building
definitely
appreciate him coming on
an interesting
journey that he's been on
um
yeah just thinking about some of the
stuff that he talked about
especially from you know at the end
start talking about the
the political ramifications of things
that happen
and again again these are all things
that
i talk about these things in leadership
strategy and tactics right you give up
your influence
but at the same time like
david hackworth just get to that point
where you're not gonna take it anymore
you know when he when he was talking
about mckenzie
one thing that's interesting is he he
and i just thought of this as right
right as stu left but
you know he mentioned that
you're in that position the president
says no to your plan then it's your duty
to turn in your rank
and that is one way of looking at it for
sure
um
but also
you know the other way and i talk about
this leadership strategy and tactics
that's one thing to do or is it your
duty to
mitigate the risk of the plan that's
being utilized
that's another way to look at it as well
and
but here's where
either of those two options here's the
the point that i think is important
and this is stu would agree with this
the outcome you own
that's the difference this is something
that you know when napoleon said if you
if you follow orders
even if you know they're wrong and you
follow orders you're culpable
so that's the point
so
where
i might disagree with stu
that
it's the duty of someone to turn in
their rank
if they can't convince their boss or
turn in their resign from their job if
they can't convince their boss
that is one way of looking at it
i would say that it's your duty to
execute the plan to the best your
ability and then take ownership of the
fact that you didn't
weren't able to convince your boss take
ownership of the fact that the plan that
executed was one that you agreed to
execute and you did and it failed and
it's your fault
so
just to again i'm sure you know we'll be
able to talk about this some more in the
future but i i wanted to as i was
walking back upstairs after
after walking out
stu just thinking about that fact of
look it
again one way to say it is your duty to
turn your rank in my opinion
it's your duty to either turn to your
rank or take ownership of the plan and
take ownership of the outcome of the
plan that's what you do
so
a little nuance on that
but uh
appreciate him coming on
and again trying to trying to be able to
allow someone to share their entire
perspective
so
um
he's trying to do the right thing we're
all trying to do the right thing
yep we should be trying to do the right
thing i think so too yeah
and i think that starts with you know
improving ourselves yes
trying to do the right things in our own
world it's true yeah seems like
something we all should be doing yes
echo charles any recommendations on how
we might do that yes i i will say well
okay so my
recommendations are
about there's these four there's four
things there's actually eight but these
four things and they're divided into two
each one right this is as far as
recommendations to do to improve
yourself so you have
your relationships these two kinds of
relationships my opinion
or
that can be categorized i think
uh there's your
health
and capability
two things
um your money and what you do with your
time
and your
world view and spirituality
the four things okay essentially
so you want to improve that if you feel
like you're lacking in any one of those
pay attention to it try to improve it
good news about this about that about
this whole thing good news
we have things
that'll help you improve all these
things that's a good that's a good let's
start with the physical actually the
physical part of it i think is is a big
one you know and so you once said early
on this particular podcast sure that
the physical one will positively
influence all of them yes and factually
factually and what i didn't say which is
equally as true the physical one will
negatively impact all of them oh look at
that let it slide i'm telling you i
actually wrote about both those things
in leadership oh no in the discipline
because freedom field manual yeah
oh yeah and you know we all heard that
hey if you don't have your health you
don't have anything like you know like
that whole thing i mean yeah think about
it like if you're like okay let's say
you have the best you just landed the
best job
and it pays a lot and you love doing it
so you can't walk
the stairs you can't walk the up
or
you
now
are gonna are at risk of xyz terminals
diseases yeah no one takes that yeah
that's not a good situation regardless
of how much money you make or what if
you have great great relationships
intimate family friends great
but you neglected your health now you're
on the path to
demise
does that help your relationships no
does it hurt your relationship oh yeah
everybody's sad including you by the way
either way you see where i'm going with
this all right so let's take care of our
physical health let's improve our
physical health i like it
never too late to start my opinion well
after you're dead a little bit too late
but
as long as we're listening to this
we're alive and we're doing it uh good
news we
have some supplementation to help you on
this path
physical and mental boom here we go okay
so a big one that i actually
i don't wanna say i didn't pay attention
to it because i do take it every day but
it just sort of just you just take it as
the vitamin d3 that's immunity that's
all it's a lot of things that's a big
one yeah i feel like when i got miss
rona yeah
no factor really partially because of
vitamin d i mean i'm thinking
so i'm going to give you um that i have
the exact same story so yeah the first
time we caught it that was like 20 20
i here's i'll tell you i don't know i
didn't test positive technically but
here look we went end of 2020 right
that's when we got it like that yeah
yeah
no symptoms at all mm-hmm
not even like the actually i don't say
no to i lost my sense of smell right
that's it no fever and no cough no cough
no cough no temperature no factor didn't
miss a workout nothing my workouts as i
reviewed
i was noticed that my workouts were a
little bit weaker than normal but i just
thought i was over training or something
like this yeah you have a bad day yeah
no factor and then still got after it by
the way yeah boom right well they say if
you have a fever you shouldn't work out
you can have a cold but if you don't
have a fever you still work out check
your body will still like respond
correctly that's what i hear i don't
know
so
so this
kind of recently will say an undisclosed
time um members of my family
took a coronavirus test tested positive
so took the test
no quarantine
there's very many good reasons to
believe that i whatever they had that my
family member had i got it too good
reasonably i'm not going to go into how
or why all this stuff the next day after
that
the results come back positive right
from my family
yeah test positive
same deal of course i got it i had to
i've got it technically i didn't go take
a test and test positive so i don't know
full disclosure so again no symptoms no
symptoms no fever no cough fever no
factor no cough no factor
in fact so technically i got coronavirus
on paper that's what i got not in real
life not in the field there was no
corona virus to be seen or heard or felt
anything it was only on paper
i attribute that to
i think anyway
the care that i took of my immunity
vitamin d3 yeah cold war by the way cold
war isn't every day the cold war is like
if you see something on the horizon yeah
boom cold war all day oh yeah
pre-emptive strike on that yes sir
savagery yep so we got all that jocko
fuel cold war vitamin d3 we've got stuff
for your joints joint warfare
you know it's a theme everything is war
against this bad stuff
right because that's what it is
surprisingly enough our theme is a war
war against weakness organs disease
or robots war against robots by the way
just in case actually we like robots
from time to time nonetheless okay all
right also if you like energy drinks
or if you would like energy drinks but
you don't want the health the
ramifications that some traditional
energy drinks uh provide for lack of
better term we got something for you too
discipline go energy drink all healthy
so good no preservatives all natural
no sugar
all natural all natural fruit
all natural vitamin
vitamin b12 vitamin b6 electrolytes so
good for you oh yeah only 95 milligrams
of caffeine enough to get a little
oh yeah but not enough to give the car
exactly right
so if you're on this path and you're
down for uh energy drink scenario this
is 100 the one it'll keep you on the
path not off you drink a bad energy
drinks you're kind of off the path let's
face it not this one boom on the milk
don't forget about mulk
and look you're gonna get situations
where you're like in your life where you
have you're on the path you're feeling
good you're staying disciplined
and you just ate a freaking salad with a
chicken breast
super healthy oh yeah hell yeah then you
want a little something afterwards yes
we got you covered get a milk oh yeah
then you're do you have dessert yep
that's 100 good for you yeah so eat so
we had a scenario
actually i shouldn't even say it because
i kind of fell off the path a little bit
but we had a scenario a friend of a
friend
daughter birthday scenario
cake was involved big chunk and it was
what it was like a cupcake but it was
like way bigger yeah so but it wasn't as
big as like a
a regular sized cake i don't cake's not
that tempting to me because i only like
the frosting okay one of those games
this one was a chocolate what is
frosting do you know what it actually is
what is it it's well it depends on what
kind but normal i don't know butter
there's a lot of butter in it butter
sugar flavoring
there's like a flavoring of some sort um
like chocolate frosting it's just butter
sugar and chocolate and like cream i
think that's pretty much it yeah
that's the part i like there's a lot of
cake part i don't like that's what
cupcake's not really my thing bro i'm
like exact opposite and there are six of
them and they're huge
so you know the kids ate some it's a
birthday i get it and let it slide um
but bro those big cupcakes there's a lot
of leftovers
i'm just saying there's a lot you ain't
ham
you know but here's the thing that i
only ate one meal that day so
technically
you know
but it was it was weakness what does
that mean
so you should have had a mulch i should
have had them all
would have fulfilled the whole total
thing here's the thing it was an
opportunity it was like what do you call
it one like the bad guys come in at a
target of opportunities yeah that's what
you had exactly right
oh yeah you got beat by a freaking
cupcake right i totally did i totally
did i was doing something in the kitchen
and there was like a container the
leftovers you know how uh people when
you're younger you're like gonna go out
with your friends drinking
and you do like oh we're gonna pre-game
you ever heard of that yes sir hey we're
gonna pre-game here's a little hint
a little hint for everybody let's say
you're going to uh
watch the ufc at your friend's house or
you're going to you know your wife's got
a friend that has some part you know
whatever you're going to some unknown
realm
where you're not sure what's going to be
eaten
pregame with a mulch
oh yeah pregame of the milk that way
they show up look they show up with you
know
pizza
and instead of eating nine pieces of
pizza you just had a mulch you're good
you're so correct you're so good maybe
you have a piece you know yeah we're
gonna be social eat a piece of pizza
taste good whatever oh yeah
so i'd get before back in the day long
time ago i'd get i'd order sushi right
and you know sure some people in the
room don't really aren't really into
sushi i am
very much so and i get it when i'm like
super hungry
um next to sushi spot is a is a place
you can get milkshakes so every once in
a while i'd get a milkshake too if you
drink some of the milkshake before the
sushi it's like you're not even that
hungry for the sushi anymore
counterproductive yeah yeah because it's
not only is there calories for sure but
it's like sweet and you know what it
affects your brain pregame you
accidentally pre-gamed with the wrong
thing
it's absolutely true you pregame with
the monk
or if you're going to go out to dinner
where it's like hey we're going to this
place it's not necessarily italian food
yes
yeah look you're going to get the
chicken parm which is kind of you know
we're borderline we're brushing up
against but you're still gonna have some
pasta with it which
so no pregame yeah pregame
that's what i'm saying a little hint for
the world yeah that's a good actually
really good advice man i do that all the
time
the other thing you got to watch out for
is you you you go this is another
situation hey we're going to a dinner
party you ever go to it like one of
those
these people aren't on here on top of
things right so you show up at five
you tell me we're going to a dinner
party that means we're gonna be eating
dinner we show up at five next thing i
know it's seven o'clock that we haven't
eaten yeah yeah now i'm not happy about
the scenario right
cause guess what it's not that you're
not eating because they're putting out
freaking chips
and whatever appetizers yeah so pregame
yeah pretty game that's what i'm saying
pregame with the mulk
hey i don't want to get too technical
though now that i just realized it does
it's actually kind of the opposite it is
a pre-game technically but does the
opposite of a drinking pre-game i've
always heard of pregame as the drinking
yeah oh yeah that's that's the only way
i've been in the drinking pregame you
drink to get more
liquored up get liquored up you don't
drink the milk to get more
full yeah i guess i guess kind of it's a
positive pregame that's what we're
talking about so pre-game nonetheless
very constructive
beneficial if you want any of this stuff
go to jockofield.com
if you subscribe to it shipping is free
if you want to pick up some of the
energy drinks that's actually good for
you go to wawa
if you want to pick up any of this stuff
go to vitamin shop
and
you can get better it's true better at
life oh yeah better healthier fuel.com
it's a big deal also origin
origin usa american-made stuff no i'm
this isn't just any kind of stuff it's
like american-made denim
jeans
boots leather stuff i i would say if you
want to clarify it a little bit more
without going through a list of stuff
you could say american-made stuff that
you actually need right oh yeah this is
stuff that you actually need this is the
what do you what do you need well you
need you need jeans
you need shorts you need a sweatshirt
you need a t-shirt you need a beanie you
need the stuff you need you need boots
you need a ghee
jiu-jitsu
what are you going to train
nokia oh wait you're training oh yeah
that's fine too but you need a rash
guard yes so there you go go to
originusa.com
you can get all this stuff that you
actually need
which is a good idea and it's all made
in america too by the way even the the
materials
everything
100 made in america
down to the thread down to the rivets on
the jeans the zippers on the jeans you
know the buttons even even the buttons
it's true bro that's true
also jacques was a store if you want to
represent on the path discipline equals
freedom the idea good if something
happens that's not that great there's
going to be some good anyway if you want
to represent dracostore.com that's where
you can go we also have a subscription
situation called the shirt locker and
these are
additional designs that you can only get
once well i guess now if you're a member
you can log back in the store and get
other designs from before so we do have
that feature
that's a big deal we didn't have that
before i'm just saying it's a new
feature oh yeah put this guy in for a
nobel peace prize over here on that one
it's a good one that's a good big deal
man big deal did you put release of you
know a
a news article about that that's what's
available look at this let's just say
it's a big thing okay so you see what
i'm saying but yes jacquelinestar.com
you want to represent you want to check
it out if you like something get
something also subscribe to this podcast
we also have the
unraveling podcast we have the ground up
podcast the warrior kid podcast you can
also join us at the underground
jockowunderground.com
there's weird things happening out there
there's people being banned shadow
banned
there's videos being censored which is
crazy
yeah like we talk about china and the
fact that they ban parts of the internet
and social media they you are not
allowed yeah and here it is happening
here in america
oddly enough
what is the what do you think is like
the
above board
not even above board what what is the
motive you think man banning someone
driving a narrative i feel i'm sorry man
i feel like someone who's respond i mean
i'm sure there's a group of people who
are responsible for that and they're
kind of running the banning but what is
it like what is the conclusion that they
come to be like you know what we should
really just ban this driving a narrative
they're driving a narrative and here's
here's what sucks
is the worst thing you can do to try and
drive a narrative is not let people talk
because if someone has a dumb idea the
best thing you could do is let them talk
about their dumb idea so we can say hey
here's your why your idea is dumb
what's scary is when we let ego get
involved and instead of me saying you
know what echo's got a opinion
i'm not sure if he's right or not but i
think he's wrong so therefore i'm going
to ban him
i should be like well echo's got an idea
if that idea actually has merit we
should bring it out in the open we
should talk about it and see if it's
right or wrong or maybe not necessarily
right or wrong this is where it's this
is what this is what's scary not
necessarily right or wrong
everyone wants everything to be black or
white science
science isn't black and white
science changes
so when you say something
is wrong what how many things are
actually wrong
not too many especially when you have
evolving situations whether they're
political situations medical situations
these things evolve
and so to just say you know what we're
not going to let you talk about your
idea
is really crazy
and it's happening that's why
we made the jocko underground jocko
underground.com it's a a place that we
control
we don't control this platform that
you're listening this to right now
unless you're on the underground so if
you want to help us out in the
underground have a little sanctuary
of freedom
you can go to jackonground.com you can
subscribe it costs 8 18 cents a month we
do an additional podcast to say thank
you
answer your questions talk about some
some
correlating
subjects
so check that out if you can't afford it
we still want you in the game we still
want you to be free
so you can email assistants at
jockleunderground.com if you want some
of that
we have a youtube channel by the way
where
we are making really good videos and
straight up look this is really really
really good the video that you made with
the robots oh yeah yes
that was insanely impressive
did you even put it did you put it on
the youtube channel uh yeah
yes put it on the youtube channel
because that is really good like i was
very impressed
look i know you're good i'm not trying
to say that i have low expectations
i have the highest of expectations sure
because you've made some really good
stuff in the
past this one i understand and you know
what to be honest with you i wasn't even
the assistant director on this one kind
of bummed me out okay maybe a little bit
better all right there's a couple little
pointers i could have added you know a
couple little plot line could have been
a little bit you know tightened up but
from a graphics perspective
it's amazing so if you want to check out
some of those videos that echo charles
makes in his head and then makes them in
actuality
subscribe to that origin usa has a cool
channel too
subscribe to that i made you know what i
made
i made a
mp3 um album
yes yeah oh yeah psychological warfare
of course yeah that's the one this album
you talk about it does have tracks on it
each track is literally the solution for
any moment of weakness you might have
the common ones apparently i need to
make one for cupcakes
because you got ambushed by a cupcake
bro it was that was like
it was like too fast for me to be like
oh let me pop in freaking psychological
warfare i don't even think i have my
phone you got ambushed i got hey hey
look
what used to be 100 effective is now no
longer well i didn't put it in if i put
it in and i still chose to eat the
oversized cupcake
which had a very
large front-end benefit by the way
um then it would not have been 100 but
you know i chose not to to you know to
put it in
but nonetheless you put it in 100
effectiveness it'll get you past these
moments these common moments of weakness
skipping the workout nope you won't skip
the workout
but today i didn't i wasn't about to
skip the workout at all but you know
every time when you you talk about like
oh yeah when you wake up and it's cold
but it's so warm in the bed yeah today
was literally like that this morning
it's a little chilly out there didn't
eat it though
it actually even took a cold shower just
kind of prove to yourself i got the cold
tub oh and i gotta get into it brother
the cold shower you know they say
one of the benefits is like it it
exercises your mind to do something you
really don't want to do so that way like
mentally every everything else seems
like i don't know easier or whatever um
i i guess
even though you really don't
that's not the first thing you want to
do go on a cold shower or cool down when
you wake up
usually but when you get out you do feel
like dang some
other stuff got awakened in your body or
whatever it's a good way to wake up yep
it's true um flipsidecanvas.com dakota
meyer making cool stuff to hang on your
wall check that out got a bunch of books
final spin
somebody just posted the last page of
final spin which we gotta admit it's
kind of cool
so
i was like it looks so cool to see that
last page posted because the way it's
laid out and stuff
final spin check that out leadership
strategy and tactics field manual the
code the evaluation the protocol
displays freedom field manual
way the warrior kid one two three four
get your kids on the path get the
neighbors on the path
mikey and the dragons about faced by
hackworth quoted from it today
extreme ownership and the dichotomy of
leadership that i wrote with my brother
leif babin
also we have a leadership consultancy
echelon front
leadership is the solution to your
problems i don't know what your problems
are but i know leadership is the
solution inside your organization go to
echelonfront.com for details on that you
can also check out some of the live
events that we have we have the muster
two-day conference
we have field training exercises which
are two days you spend out in the field
learn how to maneuver and then lead
in simulated combat missions you will
feel
your leadership improve
battlefield where we go out and walk
historical battlefields
and talk about the lessons learned from
the good and bad calls made by leaders
so check all of that stuff out at
echelonfront.com we also have
an online training academy for you
to assist you in taking ownership of
your life the various
skills in life
that will
that will make you
better that will put you in a better
position
that will help you overcome scenarios
that we all face
so if you want to take ownership of your
life
go to
extremeownership.com i'm on there two
three times a week live you want to ask
me a question good go on there and ask
me a question
you wanna you wanna dive a little bit
deeper into extreme ownership go on
there we have courses that you can go
through when you want to put your team
through extreme ownership training go on
there get your team unified behind the
same
principles
extremeownership.com if you want to help
service members actively retire their
families gold star families check out
mark lee's mom mama lee she's got a
charity organization that does
incredible things
for
veterans and their families if you want
to donate or you want to get involved go
to americasmightywarriors.org
and if you want to hear more from
me
talking a little too much
or you want to hear from echo
who's
barely talking and still talking a
little bit too much
you can find us on the interweb
on the gram on facebook
on twitter echo's addict with charles
i'm at jacqueline i'm also on
what's it called
getter g-e-t-t-r i'm on there now too
i'm on there so also check out stuart
sheller at stuart cheller on all those
different um categories and he's also
got that website
authenticamericans.com and thanks once
again
to
stuart sheller for coming on sharon has
a view on things thanks to him for
trying to make a difference and thanks
again stuart sheller for your service in
the marine corps to our country and
thanks to all the military personnel
out there right now trying to make a
difference in the world
trying to keep it safe for freedom by
doing what few people will do and the
same goes for our police and law
enforcement
firefighters paramedics emts dispatchers
correctional officers border patrol
secret service all first responders
thank you for keeping us safe and
protecting freedom here at home
and everyone else out there there are a
lot of forces at work in the world
a lot of strings being pulled a lot of
decisions being made there are agendas
and personalities and people sometimes
look out for their own self-interests
and that's okay sometimes in most cases
that's good
because when we're all looking out for
our own self interest then collectively
we're moving forward but sometimes
people's self-interest starts to hurt
others
especially from a strategic perspective
when people start to
look at their own self-interests and it
helps them but it hurts us as a whole
from a strategic perspective
that's when you may have to step up and
try and do it tactfully and try and do
it through influence and by building
relationships and by guiding others in
the right direction and if none of that
works
then
think strategically
about how to handle your next steps do
the calculus
don't let your emotions drive your
decisions
think about that indirect approach from
b.h liddell hart
think about the effectiveness or the
ineffectiveness of being direct
and then make sure you are staying true
to your principles and what you believe
in after all
in the end
you have to look yourself in the mirror
and you have to be able to look yourself
in the mirror and know that you did the
right things for the right reasons
so move with caution
but also with conviction
and until next time
this is echo and jocko out